欢迎来到知情小酒馆。这是一档有知有行出品的播客节目。
我们关注投资，更关注怎样更好的生活。我是羽白。
最近的几期小酒馆，我们聊过农业，也聊过疲惫经济学和内在的资本主义。
这些话题聊到最后，好像都会回到同一个问题。
工作、劳动和金钱到底和一个人的价值是什么样的关系？
所以，这次的小酒馆故事会，我们向听友争计了一个问题。
在工作和收入之外，还有什么在支撑你的价值感？
这里当然不是说工作和金钱不重要。
只不过，如果一个人太久，只用工作、收入和头衔来理解自己。
很容易会把我是谁这个问题，交给外界的评价来回答。
好像只有工作顺利，我才是好的。只有收入继续增长，我才是安全的。
只有在一个系统里被认可，我的努力才算数。
可人生中总会有一些时刻让我们意识到，我们不能只靠这些东西来确认自己的价值。
它可能是一段突然转弯的生活，可能是一只被你带回家的小猫小狗。
可能是一次财务危机之后终于说出口的求助，可能是一段来不及好好告别的关系。
也可能是走了很远之后才开始问自己。
这条路到底是不是我自己想选的？
那今天这期节目，我们选择了五位听友的故事。
他们的经历各不相同，但都在某个时刻意识到，工作和收入无法代表自己。
远的这些之外，还有想陪伴的人，有想照顾的生命，有重新捡起来的爱好，也有需要坦承一对的人生课题。
希望这期节目你也会喜欢。
第一位听友小洋，是一位编剧。
看到他投稿之后，我忍不住去偷偷搜了一下他的作品。
搜完之后第一反应是，哇，真的很厉害。
小洋很小就开始写作，后来做了编剧，有自己的代表作。
按理说，这是一个创作者一路努力，终于获得回报的故事。
但他投稿给我们，想聊的不是成功之后，我怎么看待自己？
而是一个靠写故事为生的人，突然对创作失去了热情。
就在去年，小洋进入了一段直接倦怠期，以前他会很认真的投入一个项目，
也会在作品播出时和朋友一起看弹幕，看反馈。
可到了去年，这些事情突然很难再让他兴奋起来。
偏偏也是在这个时候，他成为了妈妈，也不得不重新面对母亲的病情。
一个新的生命刚刚开始长大，另一个对他来说也很重要的生命，却在慢慢的走向别里。
在这样的处境里，他决定带着丈夫和女儿回到河南老家生活一段时间。
这听起来像是一个很大的生活转弯，但对小洋来说，
他可能也是一段很难再拥有第二次的时光。
所以，我也很想听他讲一讲，在这样一段并不轻松的日子里，
他是怎么重新理解工作，也重新理解生活的。
非常感谢小洋给我们的投稿，你可以先给大家简单的自我介绍一下。
好，大家好，我叫小洋，我是一个影视剧的编剧，也是一个新手妈妈。
前面小洋简单的讲了一下我们扯前一篇，提到了那个比较艰难的时刻。
其实是我们之前聊天的时候，我有提到我有朋友也在做编剧。
今年终于有了一部，他可以署名的作品播出。
我觉得真的是太难了，然后想要就告诉我说，从零到一，
拥有署名这一部可能就是最难的，之后就会顺利很多。
我也很好奇，对于一个从河南新乡来到北京生活的小城女孩来说，
你觉得这份工作最早带给了你什么？
你当年是因为喜欢文学而开始做这份工作，还是说你就是很喜欢编剧？
我其实是个很俗气的人，我是一个因为这个工作有很好的报酬。
真的吗？
给我展现了一个非常体面的生活状态，然后我才进入这个行业的，
因为我家境其实并不是很好，然后高中的时候，
其实就一直在写作来贴补家用，高中啊，不贴补家贴补我自己。
所以就是其实可能一直在写作吧，
然后等到上大学的时候，因为当时要工作，我也去找了一些实习单位，
但是我发现我这个人我做不了班，就是我坐在那我难受，
然后我就想要考虑一下我是不是可能会有一个自由职业的这么一个选择，
然后我就给曾经的一个可能在写作的时候打过交道的一个朋友，
发了一个简历，他那个时候已经是一个编剧了，
他就让我去面试，然后我就去面试我的就是我现在的搭档，
然后我就发现他怎么这么有钱，
就他的那种生活途径深深的震惊了我，
不是这是哪一年的事情，
2017年的事情当时我们家养猫，
然后我跟我先生那个时候都很穷苦，
我们家的猫吃的是三块钱一个的猫罐头，
然后他们家的猫吃的是三十六块钱一个的猫罐头，
我回家觉得好对不起我家的猫，
然后我就觉得也许有可能我也可以在这个领域上面试试看，
然后也很顺利的就进来这个工作室，
当时最开始的时候是当枪手其实也没什么收入也别提署名，
但是那个时候就是身体比较好，比较能熬夜，
然后也就慢慢的坚持下来，
就如果要说可能聊到我们今天的正题，
就说是什么促使我，
可能想要在事业上证明自己，
我觉得最开始的时候确实是自尊心可收入，
希望收入能提高以及希望能够在这个非常功利的影视行业里面找到属于自己的位置，
我想分享一个小故事，
就是我当时第一次有项目开机的时候，
因为那个时候我只是一个小编剧相当于枪手吧，
然后我们开机之前都会有开机宴，
大家就会坐在一起吃一顿饭就所有的工作人员，
刚开始的时候我是要跟着我的大编剧一起去入座，
然后这篇人就跟我说说不好意思这个桌子座位很紧缺，
你可以到别的地方去坐吗？
然后我就坐到了一个我现在想可能是灯光或者摄影的桌子上，
然后人家的人来了就跟我说不好意思我们人正好你坐在这的话我们可能就不太方便，
然后我就又起身又换了一个更远的位置，
然后即使在更远的位置人家也都是认识的，
然后人家人数也是正好的，
然后我就又起来我就发现就是我在这个地方是没有位置的，
然后我当时其实心里挺难过的，
我因为那个时候年纪比较小，
我觉得可能是因为我做的工作太容易被取代了，
或者当时的我可能太不重要了，
所以我的这个窘迫可能就显得对别人来说甚至是有点矫情的，
然后那个时候我就觉得老娘有一天要做主桌不行，
我要努力，是在我要证明自己，
对，因为在小羊的投稿里他就说之前自己的人生完全是被事业定义的，
自己就是个工作狂，
生活完全围着工作转一天光写就可以写十几个小时，
项目开机了就觉得很成功，
黄了就很失落，
就是不最朴素的价值感就是写出不错的作品，
然后理想就是成为一个有名有耗的大编剧，
就我会觉得编剧是一个大家不太了解，
但是又因为大家竟然会看剧嘛，
会觉得很好奇的一个职业，
你在小羊能不能跟我描述一下就是大家理想中的编剧的工作生活和你们实际的最大的差别有哪些，
或者是说大家对于编剧这个工作理解的最大的误区有哪些，
我觉得误区可能就是大家觉得编剧在一个项目当中是相对的比较有话语权，
或者是大家的误区可能就是大家会觉得什么事情都归编剧馆，
比如说我也写了嘛，
我说我们的那个稿费主要是三部分组成，
一部分的是窝囊费，
就是可能你要平衡各方的意见啊，
这些意见虽然让你拿过来，
你有些看着互相打架都很扯淡，
那这些意见你就要去处理和解决，
他这部分钱我管他叫窝囊费，
然后一部分钱的就是挨骂费，
就是这个项目播出了之后，
不管这个项目成色怎么样，
编剧基本上都会挨骂，
第三部分才是我认认真真工作的报酬，
那么就第二个点来说，
大家肯定会去说编剧是因为相应的觉得编剧在这过程当中扮演了一个比较重要的角色，
或者对项目有一定的话语权，
剧本剧本一剧之本嘛，
对，但就我的体验来说我觉得可能还是需要再发展发展，
我相信一定有比较有能力的编剧，
他们可以在项目当中去起到一个非常正面的作用，
但我个人的话还是会经常的被各种各样的意见困扰，
因为大家诉求和利益是不一致的，
就我拿到一个意见，
就可能可以拿到很多方的意见，
我拿到这些意见的时候，
制片人会问这个我们要怎么办，
他们有些人可能是焦虑的，
有一些人可能是自信的，
有一些人可能是有自己的立场跟态度的，
那我就要告诉他没关系我来处理，
就情绪稳定是第一性的，
情绪稳非常稳定，
就是要把这些相对还有一定理解文凯的意见给他落实到文本层面，
就是让大家都得到一定程度的安抚，
其实我说句实在话，
我觉得大部分的项目在进行比较靠后的修改的时候，
已经脱离了我最初可能想要集中去表达跟创作的东西，
就更多的是为了能够让你今天提了一个意见，
你看我非常尊重你的意见，
并且我把它落实到了文本里，
就是我是非常的认真的考虑了你提这个意见的合理性，
并且我努力的想让你的表演更加的舒适一些，
我觉得编剧现在就像一个情绪按摩师，
就是他在某个阶段的时候，
他需要能够起到这样的作用，
以保证项目在内容层面可以顺利的推进，
并且我认为我有的时候会为自己拥有这样的能力而感到自豪。
因为确实是解决了非常困难的题目，
你想哥哥和姐姐都希望自己有人设高光，
都希望自己是那个看起来就是解决问题，
拯救苍生的那个角色，
那这个故事怎么推进呢，这推进不了呀。
是的，是的，所以对我来说，
除非有一些东西他真的是挑战了我个人的价值观，
不然的话，
我觉得只要他不影响故事大的框架跟人物走向，
我还是会比较积极和窝囊的去进行调整。
那播出时被骂不会感到特别的委屈，
我觉得还好，
一个是因为这个是我们工作的一部分，
窝囊费已经收了，
而且大家他看这个东西，
并且认为这个地方不是特别符合观众的关剧期待，
一定是因为他本身出现了问题，
那所以我觉得作为这个项目内容方面的，
可以说编剧算内容方面的负责人吧，
然后去应该承担一定的责任，
不管这个东西是不是我们主观上造成的。
那你有经历过被观众或者粉丝骂的很狠的这种事情吗？
我是个幸运的人，
我期间还没有被骂到就是崩溃的地步，
一定会有人提出质疑，
像我上一个戏，
我天天每天早上一睁眼就会收到我妈给我发来的小作文，
我妈就会质问我为什么，
为什么其中的某个角色要这样，
他真的给我妈添了很多的赌，
然后我妈就会觉得我为什么要写这样一个人物出来，
就怎么怎么样呢？
我要跟他解释，
我还不能跟他剧透，
我说你先看一看，
这说明阿姨看到很上头，
对也能这样自我安慰吧，
然后某一天这个人物可能不再是原本的那个状态了，
他有一些突破，
那我妈也会觉得说你这样写好像也挺好的，
所以我觉得很多观众跟我妈妈的心理是一样的，
就是大家会对这个人物有一定的情绪或者对情节有一定的情绪，
其实就是因为大家多多少少正面负面的还是被他给刺激到了吗？
因为我们其实很希望大家因为看剧而产生一定的喜怀乐，
这不就是大家看剧的意义所在，
所以我觉得还好。
可是我觉得这样听下来，
因为你要做很多创作之外的事情，
他其实对你长期来说应该是挺消耗或者是磨损很多，
尤其是到了后期你会觉得自己还是在创作吗？
还是说你其实是在维护一个庞大的这样的一个剧组机器的运转？
你真的很会问问题，
我觉得是的，
因为刚开始的时候进入一个项目一定是怀揣着一定的表达冲动和创作热情，
然后在不断的被推翻和重塑的过程当中，
很多时候就会忘记自己到底想要写的东西是什么，
以及为了能够让这个项目能够顺利的推进，
我觉得大部分的时候我是一个会妥协的人，
在之前要之前，
所以到后面可能他已经面目全非了，
那你对他的感情也会损耗，
你自己的热情也会损耗，
所以我过去的半年其实都没有太接触，
没有太接心的项目，
就在接项目之前我都会想象到这个项目里我要吃的苦，
你大刚可能要写十遍，
第一遍的时候你满怀热情，
然后全是创作冲动，
说我要通过这个人物表达这个，
要通过那个人物表达那个，
我要让他们这样谈恋爱，
我要让他们那样快乐，
我要让观众看到这一段的时候，
感觉自己在雨中跳舞，
然后改到第十遍的时候就想算了，
你想怎样就怎样，
就已经到这种状态，
然后大刚完了之后再往后还有分级，
还有分场，还有剧本，
然后剧本完了之后开机之后可能还要有新的调整，
我就会想到这个过程我就很抵触，
所以我觉得自己当时可能也是到了一个职业倦态期，
我就主动的选择了，
就是一定程度上去减少自己的工作量，
当然家里也有一些变化嘛，
然后把经历啊什么的相对的投射出来，
能够让自己有一些个人的生活，
然后体验一些跟平时过去很多年的那种。
比较规律的那种工作状态不太一样的东西，
它是有一个很具体的时刻吗，
还是说它是慢慢发生的变化，
就是因为你在投稿里也写嘛，
就是在去年你就会突然感觉自己对作品没有这种情感，
我觉得可能是有具体的时刻就是我当时刚刚生完孩子，
我是星期五生的孩子，
然后我是下个星期四复工的，
相当于修了一个星期不到，
你不是你在产床上复工吗，
你就是在病床上复工吗？
我在家我生完两天就回家了嘛，
在家复工的，
然后我当时就是激素确实咱们女性真是被激素支配了一生，
我当时激素皱降那个时候状态就很差，
然后同时呢，家里面就是我妈妈也生病，
我妈妈她前几年的时候就得了病，
当时已经治得比较好了，
但是去年在我运气她又出现了复发的情况，
所以我那个时候很无力我就感觉原来就是生活当中很多东西真的不是我可以去控制的，
我努力工作解决不了一切问题，
我只能解决医药费的问题就会有一种失控的感觉，
然后另外一方面呢就是孩子的出生，
你看到了一个新的生命，
然后你感受到了生命的那种最初始的状态也会有一定的刺激，
然后我发现了一个共性，
就是因为我妈妈已经涉及到一个医学生存期的问题了，
虽然我很不愿意面对，
但是我觉得确实我也预判会有这样一天，
然后在人的生命可能会走到比较靠后阶段的时候和人的生命刚刚开始的时候，
其实这个阶段的人他对过去和未来都是不在意的，
大家不会有焦虑，
然后也不会有这种被世俗的成功啊，
或者说就是像我们这种优际主义受害者会产生了这种痛苦也好什么也好，
对他们来说生活和生命本身都变得很纯粹，
他们只有当下啊？
对，他们只有当下，
比如我女儿她因为我们是自己大孩子，
我们是没有老人帮趁忙，
我跟我先生就真的是目睹着她是怎么学会翻身的，
她刚开始的时候她躺在那儿肌肉是没有力量的，
她首先要抬起她的脖子，
然后她要用手慢慢的把上半身撑起来，
然后左腰右晃在某一个节点，
然后她突然之间就由这个仰臥变成了腹臥，
但她胳膊还压在自己的肚皮下抽不出来，
这个时候她就会茫然无措地挖挖大哭，
然后过几天她慢慢的就会找到方法把自己的胳膊抽出来，
这个时候她就完成了她人生当中的第一次翻身，
就是我从她身上其实看到了一种就是天呐，
我们竟然都是这样过来的，
我们的人生也曾为了一次翻身而如此的努力，
就是我们现在觉得这么司空见惯的事情，
在当时人生比较初始的阶段竟然需要花费这么多的力气，
这么用功的不停的尝试，
我觉得生命非常了不起，
然后我当时的感受就是我觉得生命其实是一个很积极的东西，
就是我们现在想要的东西这么多，
但她那个时候想要东西却这么少，
而且她翻身翻过来的时候，
她看着我们笑，
然后开心的就是拍床，
不是为了寻求我们对她的赞扬，
因为她都理解不了表扬这件事情，
她就是由终的跟世界分享她的那种喜悦，
我是真的被这个喜悦深深的感染，
而且我以前的时候会觉得就是所谓的生育让生命更完整这件事情，
我非常讨厌这句话，
我觉得她好像意味着女性一定要兑现自己的生育价值，
然后你的人生才会完整，
但我真的这半年我通过自己生活的调整跟我女儿的相处，
我发现所谓的这个完整其实是，
她让你看到了我们人生最初没有记忆的时候，
那段时光你是怎样度过的，
帮助我们找回最原初的记忆，
是的是的，
最开始的时候我们的脖子抬不起来，
我们的肌肉没有力量，
然后我们看不清东西，
我们甚至不知道自己有手，
但是我们还是长成了今天了不起的样子，
所以我就觉得这是一件很伟大的事情，
所以我就从这个过程当中确实也感受到了很多的力量，
就是她消解了一定程度上的这种。
因为是足意义的要求而产生的对自我的这种剥削。
因为基于想要你之前对自己的描述，
比如说你从高中就开始拼命的写稿准稿费，
包括后面很努力的做编剧，
就是感觉你在工作上投射了大量的自我的价值，
那你决定减产不再接那么多项目，
我在想这个过程你应该也挺坚，
它肯定不是，
我突然有点想通了，
我就不要接那么多项目，
然后我就非常顺利的带着家人都搬回了河南。
对，我觉得这过程其实挺坦克的，
因为它的焦虑感主要来源于两个方面，
第一个方面就是纯工作层面，
就是我非常担心会被行业抛弃或者遗忘，
就是现在已经如此不景气了，
然后我还挑三减四，
如果要是我可能一两年都没有很好的作品输出，
那别人在重新去想起你的时候，
都会有顾虑觉得你是不是还能保持一个比较好的创作的惯性，
你对市场是不是还是足够的了解。
那如果我做出了这样的决定，
我其实要负起这个风险的，
就是我可能的事业发展不会再像之前那么的线性和那么的连贯，
然后这个是一方面就担心自己会失去，
然后第二个方面是担心自己回到老家不适应，
因为我们最开始就说起来都简直都有点傲慢，
我在搬家之前非常的难受，
因为我们是从上海搬回新乡，
我特别担心快递送不上门，
我不想去快递站取东西，
我的记忆还停留在有一年空气不是很好，
我回家然后买了一个空气精华器，
我跟那个快递小哥说你好，
这个有点大能不能方便你帮我送上来，
然后快递小哥说这是不可能了，
然后所以我当时就觉得要回来了，
是不是这种生活能够让我适应，
甚至我先生是个黑龙江人，
他都没有来河南生活过，
所以我就也担心他适不适应，
然后猫适不适应，
狗适不适应，
宠物医院行不行，
我们家最大的猫已经12岁了，
万一他你们家几口啊，
我们家八口，
什么八口，
然后四只猫一条狗，
我先生我和我小孩，
哇这好大一家子，
大家族对，
就是大家要为了我的这个决定，
改变自己的生活状态，
其实我真的会很焦虑，
但是我觉得回来之后，
这些问题其实都还好，
一方面是我发现工作方面嘛，
因为也接触了新的项目，
然后也有比较好的一个重新启动的机会，
然后以及在这个过程当中，
其实我一直还是在写作的，
直播就是没有在写剧本，
我只是在写一些自己当妈妈的感受，
包括我当下的一些焦虑和情绪，
我觉得可能让我能够更坦诚地去面对自己，
然后看到自己到底想要的东西是什么，
然后另外一方面的是回来之后，
发现很多焦虑是白焦虑，
因为京东就是送上门，
然后工作也会找上门，
对以及去快递站也挺好的，
我先生现在可爱去快递站，
他去那边学习河南话，
然后他那天回来之后，
就坐在餐桌边，
没头没尾跟我说一句说，
吃个快递吧，
我说你干嘛，
偷着我心血是不是特别的标准，
真的还挺标准的，
然后就是我会觉得有很多东西是，
比我当时搬家之前想的要好得多的多的多，
包括我也分享了吗，
说跟我表妹一起，
我们俩骑共享电动车去吃虾仔虾，
正好碰到了那个落日，
然后我们就一直炒着太阳那边骑，
然后当时是春天，
就是初春的时候，
那个花在两边的那个行道树上就是开的简直就是爆裂，
我当时觉得太美好了，
你们这是真正的落日飞车，
对对对，
我晚上出于跑步回来的时候，
就经过我们家旁边一条街，
上面全都是饭店，
他们会，
这个季节就已经开始把桌椅都摆在那个外面了，
然后大家都坐在马路牙子上吃，
我又从他们旁边经过，
我想听听大家在聊什么，
结果大家就在聊家人，
然后聊追星，
聊对象，
然后聊动物，
然后聊马斯克，
聊雪花落，
没有人聊工作，
他每个人都好快乐，
也没有人聊AI，
没有人聊AI，
我被这个就是深深的，
我就站在路边站了很久，
我看到他们快乐，
我也觉得很快乐，
因为我觉得我身处这个生活之中，
然后我意识到作为一个编剧，
我之前的生活是很愧法的，
就是这种愧法来源于，
我在北京住的时候，
我是住在朝阳路河马后面的小区，
但我在那个小区住了四年多的时间，
我去河马的次数趋之可数，
我都叫到家门口，
然后我在上海的时候，
一公里的地方就有一个山路，
我也叫到家门口，
然后我回到家之后，
我们现在一家三口，
一周大概三天的时间，
我们回去逛超市，
然后我就发现，
你可以看到很多很多种的生活形态，
然后你身处其中，
就会有一种很踏实，
很快乐，也很浪漫的感觉，
我觉得这个感觉其实是很珍贵的，
你长久的在一个比较封闭的状态里，
人就会慢慢的变得傲慢跟懒惰，
你会只用自己理解的世界的方式去理解世界，
跟去描述这个世界，
然后我有的时候看我写的东西，
我就会觉得这个东西，
它很变形，
它既不是真实的，
让它又不是我自己想表达的，
那么我创作它的意义是什么呢？
当然也是为了混口饭吃，
但是明明其实可以有更好的方式或者途径，
明明可以比现在做的更好一点，
那我现在就是会，
就我现在在创作的项目，
其实它就已经不是偶像剧了，
就它会有一点浪漫的色彩，
在生活之上有一点浪漫的色彩，
但是情绪跟生活状态都是很真实的，
然后我自己也很能理解其中人物身处其中的悲欢离合，
我可能也能更好地帮助他们去表达他们的命运，
它比我在北京或上海，
然后我坐在某一个会设立，
或者我坐在某一个我自己的小房间里面去写，
对我来说感觉美妙了很多，
而且我们现在的生活就不止是我，
不是之前说担心我们一大家子的人都会生活上有变化吗？
我先生他之前在上海的时候他打篮球，
他每次都要换上篮球衣，穿上篮球鞋，
然后开车20分钟去一个篮球馆打，
他在我们家这儿就我家楼下有一个水泥地上面有一个破篮球杆，
连网都没有，
但是真的很神奇，
每天从下午到晚上都有人打球，
然后我先生也去打，
他也不换衣服不换鞋，
他想起来就抱着球下雨打一会儿，
然后旁边就是菜地，
就本来是物业的地，
但是被那个老爷爷老奶奶寝肯的开采了，
他们就在这个菜地里老坐，
然后我先生在旁边打球，
现在跟他一起打球的就是小学生，
但他也每天都很快乐。
前面我也会再想说，
你这么大的生活的转变，
其实家人的支持也很重要，
包括你在头发里特别标注了，
就是感谢你先生做出的牺牲嘛，
就是放下自己的工作陪你回老家，
然后就听你说他每天非常快乐地学河南话，
我觉得他也是个心很大，很乐观的人。
因为我先生他也不介意我说他的事情，
因为他在北京的时候他有非常严重的抑郁症，
然后这个抑郁症困扰了他很多年，
其实也困扰了我很多年，
我当了很多年的这个家属，
但是就是搬回来之后，
可能大家情绪上也比较松弛了，
再加上生活有了更大的命题，
一方面是我妈妈身体需要照顾，
虽然我觉得我心态还挺好的，
但是人是不可能永远活在这个世界上的，
我也是。
以及小朋友的出生他也是一个很大的命题，
我们要怎么样成为一个好的父母，
我们要怎么在他最需要陪伴的年纪给他需要的东西，
所以就是我们两个现在就是在宏大叙事之下，
反倒没有了之前的很多负担跟顾虑，
就真的只能专注当下，
我刚搬回来的时候非常难过的一点，
就是我跟我先生说我说，
我妈这个情况她肯定是很难预判，
那肯定是会有好的可能性，
但是我好像搬回来就是为了离别，
我非常不喜欢这种感觉，
然后他就跟我说，
他说他有点动容的，
他说你很幸运，
他说不是每个人都有机会可以好好的，
就是很漫长的去跟家人好好的告别，
然后我当时，
我当时觉得很好，
就是我有这样的机会，
我的工作也支持我，
我的家人也支持我去过这样一种生活，
我觉得我真是一个超级幸运的人，
所以我就觉得挺好的。
我觉得我很难想象你现在的状态，
就是你现在的这个状态是你同时，
在面临一个生命在逐渐的，
可能不是太礼貌，
可能在逐渐的逝去，
而另外一个新生的生命，
它在逐渐的长大，
对,
而你是把这两个生命连接起来的人？
是的,
所以我觉得现在的体验非常的宝贵，
然后我们也会交流说，
到底什么是人生的价值或者意义，
然后我们昨天晚上聊出的一个结果是，
就是当下的生活，
如果是你五年后十年后还会想要过的生活，
那你现在的生活就是有意义的，
因为它是让你愉悦满足享受，
一定是给了你好的体验的生活，
但如果当下的生活，
你说我五年后十年后我不想再过它了，
那你现在就是在熬，
那你就要尽可能的让自己，
尽快的过渡到自己比较喜欢，
比较自在的那种模式里面去，
我们都觉得当下的生活是未来很长一段时间都会想要继续过，
甚至它结束之后会怀念的生活，
所以当这个生活是有期限的时候，
我们就会更好地去体验和抓住它，
因为我们是不可能在这长期的生活的，
因为小朋友他上学的问题什么的问题，
最终可能还是会回到以前的生活环境中去，
所以就会显得这一段时光正在人生当中特别的宝贵，
那你现在还会想要成为你投稿里最早说的有名有号的大编剧吗？
我觉得可能没有这种执念了，
就是因为我觉得以前的时候，
我找不到自己也找不到自己生活的基础，
我觉得工作上的我是一个比较能够抓得住的我，
以及我总觉得工作这个事，
我努力一点他就给我一点回报，
我摇摇牙他就给我更多回报，
我在其中收到的正反馈让我有一种惯性，
觉得只要我在这条道路上一直走，
那么我就永远都有事可做，
然后可是现在的话我就会觉得，
工作一方面是他能够满足我表达的需求，
我还是一个很喜欢文字创作的人，
但他并不仅仅局限于说我一定要把他写成剧本把他拍出来，
我现在电脑里面也讲了很多，
就有的时候自己有时候会写一点，
或者甚至有时候听咱们节目，
我听那个《风泽河罗斯众地》那一期我就写了一篇随笔，
这种东西对我来说可能也很珍贵，
我觉得我等到五六十岁的时候我回头看，
回头看的时候他看到的我是被什么东西塑造的呢，
我觉得不只是被一个一个项目，
我自己看这些我自己乱七八糟的东西，
我也能够感受到我是怎么一步一步变成后来的我，
所以我就没有执念说我一定要以一个什么样的公众形象或者是职业认同来定义我自己，
我可能不太需要这种标签性的东西了，
所以我觉得也是一种自我的解放吧，
那我写项目的时候也没有太多的顾虑，
就是觉得这个项目我要凭借这个项目怎么滴怎么滴，
我要得这个奖那个奖可能现在也没有太多这样的想法，
可能因为该得的都得了是吗，
没有我啥奖都没得过，
怎么回事白玉兰不是太具，
看一下看一下，
以前会有这种追求的，
我之前真的觉得我我这辈子应该要为白玉兰而努力奋斗，
但是后来我觉得我应该为我自己努力奋斗，
就是我应该让我想起来的时候觉得挺好的，
这一段人生挺不错的，
因为我觉得想一想我到此的时候，
我总不能躺在那儿遗憾的是我这辈子没得白玉兰棒，
我觉得我根本都不会想到这三个字，
我觉得我想到的一定是我跟家人在一起的时光真的很好，
然后我们家的跟猫和狗在一起的时候都很快乐，
然后狗也快乐，猫也快乐，孩子也快乐，
我也快乐，我先生也快乐，
就是会想到的是很积极的温暖的东西，
就是这种东西它很具体，
它就不会像白玉兰它是一个空中楼阁，
也可能这么一讲，
如果万一有制片人听节目觉得我还没出席，
不会的，不会的，
我觉得白玉兰应该是你在用心全情创作，
它可能自然而然的一个结果，
而且刚才听你描述现在就感觉现在就是最好的时光，
是我希望大家能够在遇到生活的磨难的时候，
可能会发现它同时也是一种亏证，
它会让你有一些不同的体验，
在这些体验里，你会有一些新的收获，
如果我妈妈没有生病，我不会搬回来，
我们一家会继续生活在大城市，
然后我们就会隔三岔跟我妈妈通个电话，
我们小孩可能会有阿姨来带，
然后也不是像现在这样我们俩自己带，
就是确实是因为这个东西改变了很多，
即使这个事情本身是沉重的，
但我觉得过程是非常好的，
人也不能只活一个结果吧，
就是我们刚才说的希望嘛，
我现在觉得真的就要相信，
现在你要过的就是你想过的生活，
比你如果它不是你就努力过你想要我的生活，
如果要是明天，
明天我们就集体就咬了，
那我们今天这一天要怎么过呢，
我觉得人真的是像死而生，
我妈妈教给我的，
谢谢小杨的分享，
虽然工作它不能完全定义你的价值，
但是作为观众还是很期待你未来的作品，
谢谢,
小杨在聊天里有一个动产，
我印象很深，
他说人在生命刚刚开始的时候，
和生命走到比较靠后阶段的时候，
过去和未来都变得没有那么重要，
他们拥有的就是当下，
对小杨这样一路靠着自己的才华和努力获得认可的人来说，
这并不是一件容易接受的事情，
他可以解决医药费，
可以安排生活，
可以做很多实际的事情，
但他没有办法让时间停下来，
也没有办法替任何一个生命决定他要走向哪里，
所以他现在做的事情，
不是努力让一切按照自己所想的那样发展，
而是认真的对待正在发生的每一天，
陪女儿长大，陪妈妈生活，
和表妹一起骑车追日落，
听街边吃饭的人聊天，
记录下妈妈和姐妹的童年故事，
也正是在这个过程中，
他找回了对生活的感受里，
他重新开始大量的写作，
不再是为了某一个具体的项目，
而是因为一句话，一个人，一段记忆，
让他想纯粹地把这些记录下来。
这让我想起，
之前和袁诚庚老师聊天时，
提到的那篇课文，
故事到最后，好像什么问题都没有解决，
但我们还陪伴着彼此。
我觉得这句话放在小洋的故事里，
或许也很贴切。
他回到心乡，
不是因为那里有一个能把所有问题都解决掉的答案，
而是因为在这段不会重来的时间里，
他想和重要的人待在一起。
这些陪伴不能替他回答所有的问题，
但他很清楚，
以后回头看，
这段日子一定会被他想念。
小洋的故事里有很多具体的陪伴，
接下来这位听友313的故事也和陪伴有关，
只不过陪伴的对象变成了几只猫猫狗狗。
他在投稿里写，
工作之外自己最大的价值是一个好人。
第一次看到这句话的时候，
我其实有点好奇，
因为我们常常会默认，
价值感应该来自某一个大一些的东西，
比如事业、收入、成就、或者关系里的认可。
但313的故事不是这样，
他的价值感来自很具体的照顾，
收养一只流浪的小狗，
就下一只受伤的小猫，
直到现在和伴侣一起。
撑起一个有两只猫四只狗的小家。
我很想知道的是，
这些照顾是怎么一点点发生的，
又为什么会成为他理解自己的方式？
顺便提醒一下大家，
因为313的家里实在是太热闹了，
这次录制的时候，
猫猫狗狗不满足于只做场外观众。
接下来你可能会听到一点。
小狗啪啪啪走来走去的声音，
或者猫咪偶尔喵两声，
像是在旁边补充发言。
请大家把他们理解为本期的特别嘉宾。
那让我们来听一听313的故事。
欢迎313来到我们小酒馆，
你要先自我介绍一下吗？
大家好，我是313，
然后我是一个在建筑行业央企工作了7年的大工人。
我收养了四只小狗，
然后两只小猫，
然后我跟我的伴侣现在在程度有一个小家。
313跟我们投稿的时候有写到，
其实对你来说有一个转折点，
就是之前你在工作上也非常的投入和认真，
直到去年你的上司管理层发生了变化，
然后来了一个没有太有能力，
但是很爱打压人的上级，
给你的考核差点落到了逼简，
让你开始反思这个事情。
是的，是的，就是其实这个事情是这样的，
我们公司虽然是个养企，
可是他来到我们这个四川这个区域，
整体是7年前才发生的事情，
就是我刚刚入职的时候，
其实就相当于是一个创业公司，
那个时候机构也很少，人也很少，
大家目标是一致的，
就是为了业务去努力嘛，
大家整个的考核机制都是比较向上的，
就是谁干了多少事情，
谁是怎么样的，那就是怎么样的。
但是去年呢，可能因为管理层的变化，
因为他换掉了整个部门的中层，
然后换了那个人呢，
他对我们整个四川区域的工作其实是不了解的。
按理来说，如果他不了解呢，
他就应该慢慢的去了解，
以及跟我们这种长期在这个区域呆的一些工作人员，
进行一些深度的沟通，
但是没有，
但是利用一些职权导致这个结果，
然后让我对工作这件事情，
产生了新的思考，
就是认认真真做事的人，
是不是应该被这样对待。
对，因为我看你在投稿里说，
最开始刚进这家公司的时候，
你那个时候是希望和区域共成这样？
是的,
就是觉得怎么都是希望自己能够伸出的鞋，
能够越来越好，
但是随着经济下行也好，
建筑行业往下走也好，
加上是这种扬起范体制的这种氛围内，
人际关系可能变成了一个主导的内容，
工作内容本身可能不重要了，
就是你依然有这么多事情要去做，
但是如果你去做的人，
就会承担更多的责任，
然后要一追到底，
但是你如果不做事情的人，
可能就不需要追究你的责任，
然后他身为你的管理层，
如果你这事情做好了，
就会变成他的管理能力的凸显，
但如果你这事情没做好，
就是你一线执行不到位，
就会成为一个现在这样的一个大风气，
所以就是让我对工作这个事情，
以及工作这个环境产生了一些怀疑，
就是大家听313这么说，
但313其实也并不是那种，
把工作当作定义自己价值，
唯一一种手段的人，
就你在投稿里有写过，
你说你一直都清楚工作只是你人生价值的一部分，
只是发生了这个事情，
让你开始思考，
如果说多做多错，不做不错，
那认真负责的人，
这个认真负责的意义在哪里？
是的，我18岁的时候，
我给自己承认说的一句话，
就是做一个负责任的大人，
我也一直是这么贱行，
成状的过程中，
很多选择都是我自己选的，
包括读文科也好，
包括学交换也好，
包括我自己选择的工作，
我都是自己对自己负责的，
所以我对我的工作也是负责的，
对我们的小家，对我的妈妈哥哥，
都是负责的，
所以我一直认为我是一个负责任的人，
然后如果你对待一个事情是负责任的，
再加上如果你是真诚善良的，
那么你一定是个好人，
我觉得好人不应该是一个，
好像就意味着等于你好欺负，
好说话，
但不是的，
好人不应该被欺负。
是的,
所以你在思考完这件事情之后，
你得出来的结论是什么？
我其实说实话，
我觉得就是我可能离开我的工作，
至少现在为止，
因为还有房贷跟车贷的问题，
但是面对这个情况，
你只能把做好自己本职工作的讽施，
要转换思维在职场上面，
一个是多保护自己，
然后还有一个就是，
把目光投射到对自己更重要的家庭，
以及我们家的猫猫狗狗上面来。
313的投稿有一段确实是很打动我，
比如说你的自我探索，
不是说我业余生活，
我去什么搞个敷业，
或者是培养一个爱好，
你说你的自我探索是从养第一只猫亮亮开始？
对，是猫咪改变了我，
因为我觉得我是很缺爱这个感受的人，
当然我不能苛求我父母更多，
但是从小到大的这个过程中，
我爸爸对我使用了一些家庭暴力，
跟他睡觉有关系，
所以我对最久这个事情挺那个的，
小学的时候我记得非常清楚，
我小学一年级的时候，
那个时候很小很小，
然后跟同班的朋友去捡了一个零食，
就是好玩，
就是属于那种很无知的状态，
捡了一个零食，
然后被另外一个同学看到了高道班主任那里，
当天晚上我就遭到了永生难忘记忆的一顿打吧，
一场暴力的，
然后我爸爸拿着那个衣衫巴掌，
然后瞅我眼眶，
然后第二天早上全是鱼血，
然后我还要去上学，
他一边打我的时候那个话我真的特别清楚，
说的是家里没有钱吗，
你为什么要去捡东西吃，
哇那个话真的给我到现在为止还有冲击感，
就是原来钱东西吃食物面子可以搅和在一起，
然后变成这样的事情变成对我的伤害，
所以我跟我爸爸不亲近也是在这里，
就是从小到大都是这样的，
我妈妈是一个非常理性的人，
但是她的原话也是说我当时应该被打，
但是不应该被打得那么重，
这是原话，
所以我的感情一直没有办法安放，
其实我很爱小动物，
我也很爱这个生活，
但是从养样量开始我这个爱，
他有了安放的地方，
我能够去关心他，
因为他也是一只流浪猫嘛，
他流浪猫流浪了四年之后，
他当时都受脱象了，
然后带回家了之后慢慢的养，
其实我一开始我也不会养猫，
因为我被猫抓过，
其实我还有点怕，
但是我慢慢的在养他的过程中，
好像把我自己又关怀了一次，
他感冒也好，
我了解他的身体也好，
包括他之前得纸发肝也好，
他来了，
我来了吧，
因为替你Q了，
他这个体型得纸发肝确实很合理，
但是因为之前流浪的时候过瘦，
然后导致了纸发肝，
然后他现在其实完全看不出来，
他已经十一岁了，
非常非常大了，
我已经养他六年了，
你当时收养他的契机是什么？
因为你说你之前被猫抓过，
也没有养过猫，
我觉得其实第一次养猫，
还需要下满大决心的，
其实是我的前任把他带过来的，
但是我的前任其实这个也要讲到，
就是我的前任也是一个会使用暴力的人，
当时把他带回来的时候其实对亮亮很不好，
就是因为亮亮他是一个猫咪嘛，
但是他就很希望猫咪像狗一样，
就是很长时间不见面还是那种，
就是他对亲近关系也是这种状态，
就是希望他就算不用付出什么，
他也能够获得无条件的爱，
但是我觉得我们对小动物应该首先要有无条件的爱，
至于他亏证给我们什么，
那都是他们选择的，
我们不应该对他们要求获得。
可是如果这样的话，
在上一段关系里你不会很煎熬吗？
就是不会觉得自己像是陷入了某个魔咒一样，
总是会遇到这样的人？
是的,
所以我选择了骑摩托车和运动，
就是我很喜欢骑车，
然后我喜欢那个风打在身上自由的感觉，
你那个时候觉得自己很自由，
觉得自己没有现在那个工作也好，
没有现在一些危险的关系里面也好，
是这样的，
但那个也是探索自我的过程吧，
就是可能你要经历一些，
你要仔细从那个关系中走出来，
然后从那个怪圈里面走出来，
认知到不管什么样的暴力，
不管什么样的PV和打压都是不对的，
你总要有好的幸福的生活在后面等你。
而且我看你在投稿里也写到，
就是你是因为有了亮亮，
你的精神和爱有了安放的地方，
然后从了解如何养猫，
怎么对它好，
然后不仅对它好也了解到了很多救助的渠道，
每年你都会在奖金发放的时候，
把钱捐给救赎基地，
每年断手里的救衣服也是捐助给救赎基地，
我觉得你真的很棒诶。
我还好吧，
怎么说呢，
就是这是一种习惯，
因为从其实认识到有智有行业，
好知智有了管也好，
是看野大的书，
对财务自由计划那个书，
然后认识到野大，
然后知道有智有行，
里面会讲到就是关于人生的价值嘛，
就是你拥有财富的价值是什么，
里面会有一个选项就叫慈善，
可是我觉得慈善这个词太大了，
但是我觉得每一个人去做一些。
微小的利索能及的善事，
能够对你的生活，
以及你这个人的精神是有帮助的，
因为我们现在太忙碌了，
大家都很多时候都很冷漠，
把情绪宣泄在网络上，
但是其实我们有时候需要一些真正的交流，
就是跟现实生活中的人也好，
以及一些遥远的你不认识的猫猫狗狗也好，
如果你喜欢小动物的话，
哪怕你就是不能养，
你也可以做一些遥远的帮助，
对这个世界有一点点微小的帮助吧，
然后我的伴侣他也是这样的人，
就是他也是每个月定期的去救助外面的小狗，
所以我们算是同频的人，
你们是因为这个认识的吗？
我们俩是都很喜欢小动物，
然后有亮亮坐在这儿，
我们是一家咖啡店的客人，
我是常识的客人，
因为咖啡店离我住的地方和当时的公司很近，
我会中午的时间去做喝咖啡，
他是外卖的客人，
就是他是外送的那种，
然后我们两个是因为我27岁生日那天，
我遇见了一只小白狗，
他那个脖子上挂了红绳子，
我以为他是走丢的，
但是我当时急着上班，
我就拿了一根火腿肠喂他，
结果后两天他就被咖啡店老板带回去了，
他说跟着他们走，
然后我说那他们遇到你们还蛮幸运的，
咖啡店老板就很快就要，
他们两家人就要去泰国旅行，
那个小狗又没有打完疫苗，
就必须要找一个地方要安置，
那么就找到我伴侣的当时的一个小教室，
当时他已经收养了原来的两只小狗，
我天呐，
就那个时候我们是正式的第一次见面，
怎么办，我现在脑海里有一个非常烂死的梗，
但是我不说又很难受，
因为我想到了说那个小白狗，
原来他博士的不是红线是越老的红绳，
其实他们也这么说，就非常神奇，
然后那个小狗后来就像完成了他的使命一样，
就他去不好日子去了，
就是他去了咖啡店老板贵州的老家，
然后过上非常舒适的生活了。
他完成了给你们牵线的使命，
我觉得三一三他在投稿中写自己的故事，
我真的觉得非常的美妙，
就是你说因为这个事情，
其实也是因为宠物，
很幸运地遇到了和你同品的伴侣，
相遇之前他就算了两只小狗，
你们在一起又收养了两只小狗一只小猫，
然后也是因为家里有这么多小动物，
坚定了买房买车的这个念头，
然后你就有了自己的家和自己的车。
是的，我第一次我们换租房，
是因为我们当时住的地方不够大，
我们的狗本身是安置在他的小椒室那里的，
结果，我们的猫猫狗狗，
其实除了亮亮之外，
在我爸妈那里是有性灵的，
其他都是我们自己背着养，
就是那种偷偷摸摸的在养，
然后某一天就是在小教室的时候，
被他的妈妈发现了我们在养狗，
就是他那天去敲门，
然后听见有狗叫，
然后那个时候就是小狗们就要紧急的转移，
就转移，然后就是当时就是看房子了。
你们搞得跟叠战似的？
是的，是的，非常紧急，
就当天被发现当天就看房，
然后第二天就定下来，
就先把小狗转移走，
然后这个时候就是我们第一次把空间扩大，
租到了一个相对比较大的房子，
然后买房的这个契机也是因为我父亲，
我的妈妈在前年出了车祸，
然后她是撞到了脚，
所以她的腿里脚踝那有钢钉，
去年她要把钢钉取出来，
她要做一个取出来的这个手术，
然后那个周我就去看我妈妈说了，
然后我妈妈要住在医院里，
我回家就住家里面，
我爸爸又许酒，
就喝醉了酒的时候非常可怕，
就我都已经28岁了，
我还是会觉得那种泼灭而来的那种恐惧感，
她也不是要对你行为上进行些暴力的动作，
但是那种压扣感会直接让你把你推到那种小瘦的记忆里面去，
然后她就不停地在和，
不停地跟你在念到，
然后不知道在说什么，
你也没有办法跟她正常交流，
然后在那个房子里面，
我家房子其实还蛮大的就是，
130平的界面110平的套位，
但是我觉得每次回家我都觉得好冷，
虽然说有我的房间，
可是好像又没有我的房间，
其实那个时候我觉得自己没有家，
就是这个事情推动到我去买房，
然后就很快的回到了程度之后，
就开始跟有的伴侣说没有，
我说我们去看房子吧，
你说我们打造一个自己的家了，
然后很快的就看到了，
就很快地定下来了，
也很快地装晚了，就住进来了，
然后装晚的那一刻觉得是的，
这就是我们家，
这就是以后我们两个人和我们家的。
猫猫哥哥生活的地方，
这是一种很强烈的感受吧。
我觉得听你一路讲完讲到这里，
就突然有一种好像那个，
在小的时候非常辛苦，
经历了很多磨难的小女孩，
到现在终于有了一个属于自己的家，
仿佛有了一个Happy Ending一样。
我觉得到目前为止是的，
就是可能在我们在一起之后，
已经我们需要那么多猫猫狗狗之后，
我们对自己的认知更清楚了，
也对于我们自己存在这个世界上的价值更清楚了，
那我们需要给我们自己打造一个家，
我的伴侣也好，我的猫猫狗狗也好，
他们就是对我而言最重要的家人，
而且家人就需要有一个家，
去一个他们怎么都不会被说的地方，
因为带着猫猫狗狗租房始终是不方便的，
当住进来了之后，
对我感受最深的是量量，
因为当时搬家，
他其实非常不适应就是环境的变化，
但是他来到这个家的第一天，
他就开始好奇地探索，开始打滚，
他是一直非常耗面子的老猫，
就是你如果盯着他，
他是不会做那种过期的举动，
但他会在我们看不见的地方偷偷打滚，
就很开心，
那我就知道他是很满意这个家的，
他也是很满意我们现在的状况，
那个瞬间我就觉得，
那工作也好，
跟我父母的关系也好都不重要了，
能看见他打滚开心自由的那一刻，
就是我最大的价值。
因为你在头高里有写到说，
你在之前会觉得自己是一个不值得被爱的人，
在以前成长的过程中，
竟然会感到很孤独，
其实很多有相似经历的人，
他们会选择说，
去寻求一种被爱的感觉，
会很希望别人的认可，
别人的喜欢，
但是你的选择，
我会觉得更有勇气，
你是选择主动的去付出爱，
你把爱给这些猫猫狗狗，
你去主动的关心他，关怀他，
我觉得这是一件非常勇敢的事情。
谢谢余白，
就是可能跟我自己有关系吧，
因为我做任何决定，
我都是对自己负责的，
然后我希望去付出爱这件事情，
本身就是我要做的事情，
我没有想过我要主动的去付出爱，
但是我的天性就是如此，
我看到猫猫狗狗，
或者是流浪的猫猫狗，
我就是觉得，
他们其实生活在这种城市的边缘，
已经非常可怜了，
我有时候跟我伴侣聊天，
我如果不考虑经济的话，
我可能真的会去做一些救助类的工作，
因为我觉得跟人打交道实在是太累了，
但是跟猫猫狗相处是最纯粹的，
他们不会在乎你的经济状况，
不会在乎你的社会地位。
不会在乎你，
有没有让他丢了面子，
有没有给他赢回面子？
是的,
就是没有那么多社交的叠加的关系，
但是他会给你安慰，
你给他付出的过程中，
你也治愈了自己，
哪怕他不需要做任何事情，
那如果他能过来蹭一蹭你，
过来靠一靠你，
那你瞬间就会被安慰的。
那像你们现在算是八口之家吗？
其实我们还有一只编外的柴犬，
怎么还有编外成员？
因为那一只柴犬是我伴侣他们家，
爸爸妈妈在养的，
那一只是有名有姓的，
就是但是不是我们家在养，
那个是入边的有编织的。
对对对，有入边的就是我伴侣他们家，
爸爸妈妈在长期养，
但是那狗粮是他在买，
所以也算是就是我们在物质上养他。
这样的一个九口之家，
那你们的日常生活是怎么样的？
哦日常生活其实说，
因为如果要养狗的话，
始终是要六，
就是这一点我们两个的工作大会还比较好，
因为他是那种周末的上课的老师，
所以周一到周五的时候，
基本上他就可以覆盖小狗白天的六啊什么之类的，
然后周末的时候就是我来负责，
就是我们是交叉的，
然后他上课的距离也比较近，
就是我上班比较远，
所以这个方面都是解决了，
然后每天的话可能就是我很早起来，
早上起来已经很惯性的要去铲包沙，
要去换尿店，
然后要去加凉，
然后这一套流程下来我就已经醒了。
属于你的成见唤醒仪式？
是的,
已经成为一套固定的模式，
然后下班回来之后，
你会很幸福的觉得就是，
家里的猫猫狗狗会一下子抽玄关泳来，
然后要欢迎你回家，
那个时候就一下子疲惫就瞬间卸掉了，
就是外面所有的身份都与你无关，
你只是回到家有一个很放松的地方，
跟你爱的人跟你爱的猫猫狗狗在一起，
然后周末的时间，
如果是我们两个都有空的话，
我们会开车，
有时候去穿西丸，
有时候会去找个地方吃饭，
因为程度还蛮多宠物有很多餐厅啊，
或者茶馆什么之类的东西，
就是猫猫狗都可以带。
那头疼的难题应该是带哪只吧，
应该也不可能全家出动啊。
不不不，
我们如果要带的话，
就是如果带出去旅行的话，
只会四只全带。
我们年初才去了马家沟，
就是带四只小狗去看雪，
就选了个周末，
对，看雪爬山。
就这种时刻是我觉得比较有意义的时刻。
让任何个孩子都不会感到家长偏心。
是的，是的，我们一定是要一样的，
就是给到的爱一定是一致的。
我觉得这样听起来感觉很幸福，
就是那种工作中的所有的这些烦心事，
就是心里就会想说要忍了，
是给孩子赚罐头的这个窝囊费。
对，工作还是经济技术还是底气，
因为有工作，因为有收入，
我们两个都有收入的情况之下，
所以我们的小猫小狗遇到生病的问题，
我们能够拿的出钱，
用物质上去照顾他们终生，
既然要养，就要负责终生。
我们有另外一只更小的那只小猫，
它是我们去年收养的，
那个是一个下了很久的雨的时候的一个放行的傍晚，
我还发的时候我们出去散步的时候，
看见它在翻垃圾堆，
就拖着瘸的腿在翻垃圾堆，
然后肚子非常大，然后状态很差，
我和我们就对它说了一句话，
我们对它说，你要是查我们走过来，
我们就带你走，
然后它就过来填我们俩的手，
我们就把它拿来装了一个烧烤袋子，
因为当时我们去买宵夜拿一个烧烤袋，
就把它拎走拎回家，
第二天带去医院做检查才发现，
它应该是被人踩过，
它的双腿骨折，
然后它的整个脊椎是弯的，
很严重，
它进了两次脊椎手术，
但是现在没事了，
它现在可以上穿下跳，
它现在天天在家做引体向上，
它会打我们，它会咬我们，
就是现在状态是非常好的，
一只小三花猫咪。
啊，生龙活虎。
对，是的，
就是这种时刻就觉得我们两个挣钱也好，
工作也好，
再烦也好，
有钱还是蛮好的。
这就是之前小主管也有路过去，
有钱的瞬间真好的感觉，
这种就是有钱真好的瞬间，
就是你能马上就跟他说，
哦，我同意，我要给他做手术，
我要让他的生活质量提高。
这就是那种时间，
就觉得自己有价值以及有钱真好。
那你先会觉得曾经那个很孤独的小女孩，
现在有被很好的治愈了吗？
是的,
就是我还是要很感谢。
我成长过程中遇到的很多好朋友，
就是虽然他们已经没有跟我在一个城市了，
在成长过程中陪伴我很好的朋友，
但是在这个过程中，
他们几日了我很多爱与关怀，
然后让我在很艰难的时刻过来了，
就是在最孤独的时刻，
最无助的时刻过来了，
然后在跟我的爱人相处的过程中，
以及在养猫一样狗的过程中，
我重新认识了自己，
因为我现在很流行那种话，
就是把自己重新养了一遍，
去安抚到了自己。
就是你可以跟你的父母不一样，
你有爱人的能力，
你有关怀别人的能力，
而这一切就是你的价值所在。
他不特别，
这个爱与关怀这件事情不特别，
但是他很重要。
你刚才讲这些话的时候，
我会感受到，
虽然明面上看起来是你在照顾这些，
小朋友们，
这些猫猫狗狗，
但是他们同样是你的力量来源，
你的力量源泉。
是的，他们才是我的力量源泉，
因为以前的在还在住小公园的时候，
加班到很晚，
可能有时候四点钟、五点钟、六点钟下班，
我还是会去咪一下，
但不管我几点钟下班，
亮亮总会从窗台上跳下来，
结我。
他肯定是比不过狗了，
因为狗刷就过来了，
就会拔你啊，
但是他会慢悠悠的、悠哑的，
做好一个拉伸之后过来，
咬你，跟你说，
哦，你回家了，
就是这样。
哦，真好，
那你会觉得你现在跟父母算是和解了吗？
还是说你已经找到了一个很好的。
和他们相处的方式，
你觉得就这样下去就OK了？
我觉得应该不是跟父母和解，
其实是我跟我自己和解，
因为我认为我改变不了他们，
就是他们说什么，
有些我听不进去的，
我就左耳机右耳出呗，
就是特定的一些节日回家，
看到他们就OK了，
但平常时间还是保持距离。
而且你也努力过了，
就你已经尽了你这份的力了，
所以可能这个结果有些事情，
就是没有办法强求，
很换你现在已经有很幸福的一大家子了。
你人不可能什么都拥有的吧，
然后认知到这件事情就行了，
因为跟父母的关系，
可能我现在也接受了，
我会关心他们，
他们发的任何东西我都会看，
我也会回，
我会陌视他，
但是我也只能发信息，
我没有办法就是说，
跟我爸妈打视频电话，
长聊啊，
这种形式，
我会觉得有一种不适感。
我发现你会对自己很有要求，
他们曾经那样对待你，
也在情感上陌视你，
但是你对自己有要求，
他们发消息你就会一定回，
他们有需求你就一定会，
去看他们，
去帮助他们解决问题，
我觉得跟我这个人也有关系吧，
就是我还是不太想做很冷漠的人，
就他们是我的爸妈，
不管怎么样，
他们从物质上，
从各个方面都没有回带过我，
所以该要尽的责任，
还是回到负责的这个话题上面，
该要尽的责任还是要尽的。
我觉得你让我意识到说，
其实成为什么样的人，
自己是可以选择的。
是的,
女人生家庭可能很差，
我觉得像葱花那种天崩开局，
就已经很厉害了，
可是她还是成为了她自己啊，
就是这点你可以扭转你自己的，
你可以成为你自己想要成为的人的。
就最后还是可以选择成为一个，
让自己喜欢的自己。
我就跟你聊天的这一个小时，
我也说过了很多，
而且就是感受到了很多，
美好的能量。
那真的很好。
感谢你的分享，
谢谢你的时间。
拜拜。
拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。
和313聊完之后，
我又回想起她一开始说的那句话，
她觉得工作之外，
自己最大的价值是一个好人。
我觉得这句话的真正含义是，
她选择成为一个好人。
她让我看到，
过去发生在一个人身上的事情，
并不一定决定了她会成为什么样的人。
时间不能解决一切问题。
有些伤害很难抹去，
有些恐惧也很难完全消散，
可是他们不一定要变成新的伤害，
继续传给别人。
313最打动我的地方，
是她把这些东西停在了自己这里。
她没有把自己受过的伤，
再传递给其他的生命。
想反,
她把很多的爱和经历，
给了那些更弱小，
更没有办法保护自己的小猫小狗。
也是在这个过程里，
和伴侣一起搭建一个家，
慢慢成为一个自己喜欢的人。
小猫在新家偷偷打滚，
狗狗会从玄关冲出来接她，
受伤的小猫后来可以在家里上串下跳，
这些瞬间当然不会出现在任何技巧考核里，
但是他们很真实地告诉了313，
我的爱有地方可以去，
他们也值得被好好安放。
这也是一种工作之外的价值感，
它不来自于外界一个多高的评价，
而是来自于它很清楚的知道，
我想怎么生活，我想怎么对待这个世界。
接下来这位听有小猫的故事，
画风会突然变得专满很多，
他投稿的时候说，
自己连标题都想好了，
叫花了三十万，
我终于找到了自己的命运杀猪盘。
命运杀猪盘是之前我和肖宇露的那期节目，
他提到的一个概念，
大意是，
每个人都会遇到自己的命运杀猪盘，
它就是专门针对你性格里的弱点设计的，
而命运会持续给你同样的考验，
直到你给出不一样的答案。
小猫的故事用于句话概括，
就是他曾经两次陷入网贷，
并且以代养贷，
加起来将近30万元。
但小猫愿意把这段经历讲出来，
我觉得很有勇气。
因为这里面有很多让人感到羞耻，
很害怕被评价的部分，
后果也确实很严重，
对他自己，也对他的家人，
都造成了非常真实的伤害。
所以我也想先恳请大家，
听这个故事的时候，
可以先不要着急审判他，
因为审判一个人总是更容易的。
可我觉得，
小猫的故事真的值得我们大家听的部分，
不只是他怎么欠下了这么多钱，
而是他为什么会一次次用同样的方式，
让自己深陷泥潭。
那接下来我们来听听小猫的讲述，
他是怎样两次走进了同一个陷阱，
又是怎样开始承认，
这个问题我一个人解决不了。
感谢小猫给我们投稿，
你的投稿应该是我们收到的投稿中最长的质疑，
非常非常感谢，
你要不要先简单介绍一下你自己？
大家好，我叫小猫，
我现在生活在长沙，
我投这个稿，
就是因为经历了这么这么多的事情，
也是想给大家更多的一些提醒吧。
我们或许可以从你最开始的状态聊起，
就在陷入往代之前，
你是一个非常在意自己要很体面或者说很优秀的人吗？
因为我看你在投稿里说你从小成绩就很好，
身上一直有一股傲气，
你会觉得他更像是一种自信，
还是说你是有一种压力，
就是我不能输，
又不能失败。
首先也不能说是很好，
只能说还不错吧，
因为我们那个地方算是一个小县城嘛，
在学校在班上可能学习成绩还可以，
但是放到整个中国来说，
不算是非常非常好。
没有人这样比的，
不要给自己这么大压力。
然后我觉得确实想要表现出很优秀的样子，
应该一半一半吧，一半是自信，
然后一半也是压力。
我不太知道你介不介意在节目里分享，
因为你在投稿里有讲到，
之前父母离异嘛，
连学费也要在他们之间问来问去，
这些经历会不会让你特别想成为一个。
不太需要依附任何人的人，
就是你特别希望能够独立，
不让别人操心。
我是非常非常非常希望，
直到今天，
我也依然还是非常希望想成为这样的人，
因为父母离异嘛，
然后他们的关系也不好，
小的时候我是跟着我妈妈在生活，
需要问钱的东西，
我妈妈就会让我去问我的爸爸，
然后我爸爸呢，
他又会说，
你问一下你妈妈，
就是这种反复拉扯的状态，
然后除此之外呢，
因为我们初中的时候是技术学校嘛，
可能很多家长都会自己送自己的小孩上学嘛，
但是我就没办法，
就是跟着我哥哥的爸爸一起接送我上学，
类似这种情况吧，
就让我觉得，
要么是我一直在去开口问我的父母要求资源，
要么就是我在别的亲戚，
别的这些长辈依附于他们生活，
所以我就特别特别希望自己表现得非常的优秀，
也很希望自己可以尽快的成为一个独立的大人，
这样子我就不用求任何人去完成我想做的事情。
那那个时候的你是怎么理解有能力这件事的，
是不是就是要工作好，收入高，学历好，
看起来过得也光鲜一些。
是的,
在读书的时候基本上就是成绩嘛，
我会认为必须要拿到一个我能力范围内，
我能拿到最好的成绩，
这样子比起其他的一些朋友，
我会有一点点优越感吧，
就觉得至少我的成绩是比他们好的。
然后大学毕业的时候，
身边也有很多人考研嘛，
那自己也会想说我也要就是读一个研究生，
然后读完研究生出来呢，
我可能就会找到一个更好的工作，
拿到更好的收入，
那我就可以更好的成为一个独立的人。
就是这是我过去的一个心路历程吧。
你是毕业了之后，
先工作了一阵，
然后再考的研，
还是说也是大四的时候开始第一次考研？
我是在毕业的那一年去实习了，
半年,
然后在毕业之后就回家全职考研，
那一年是已经进了副市，
然后差了零点几分没有进，
当时就觉得特别的不甘心，
就是想说再来一年，
然后当时就找了一个教授，
一边给他当科研助理，
一边继续准备考研，
但是那一年还是没有考上，
然后我就觉得好像时间也不能这么浪费了，
所以就决定走进职场。
因为我是学会计的，
当时其实已经毕业了两年了嘛，
然后应届生的身份其实已经是没有了，
我是20年毕业的，
从20年到22年经过了疫情的影响，
整个就业市场其实是不如我当初毕业的时候的了，
所以我当时其实找工作也不是非常的顺利，
投了蛮多的简历，
即使说我有一些证书也不符合他们招聘的要求，
最后也是找了一个很小很小的书所，
因为找了很久很久自己非常的焦虑，
没有收入嘛，
也没有很多静下心来，
就是慢慢的等待更好的机会的这么一个过程。
那当时一入职就后悔了吗？
刚入职的时候其实谈不上后悔，
还是很庆幸自己还能找到工作，
即使这份工作的报酬并不是很高，
但至少我有收入了，
至少我开启了一段职场，
然后我也能够去接触到真正的工作是一个什么样子，
而且我也相信就是当你开始有工作经验了之后，
跳槽或者是升职那肯定都是会有的，
只是这个起点比较低而已。
所以当时我也没有觉得说后悔，
只是觉得自己可能不应该属于这里，
我属于更大的地方，
会有这样一种想法。
所以工作了一年然后就落词了？
是的，因为确实是工资非常的低，
并且自己在有了一年的工作经验之后呢，
就觉得好像也可以出去试一试，
能不能找到更好的工作，
所以就落词了。
那你第一次开始接往，
但是在这个过程中还是说在下一份工作，
是为了解决一个具体的问题，
还是为了维持一种我过来还不错的状态呢？
孩子在被考考研的这段时间就已经开始了，
因为我是在长沙这边被考的嘛，
当时也是家里人并不是非常的支持我在考一年的这个决定，
然后我就说，那我自己去做兼职，
我不要你们的钱？
对，是的，
但是其实兼职也是非常非常的难找的，
首先我要在教授那里当科研助理，
然后呢我还要被考考研，
这两个任务之外我还要去赚钱兼职，
所以其实这个钱并不是非常的好赚，
而且你也没有什么非常好的背景，
也没有什么背书，
当时就是周末或者是晚上去做一些家教兼职，
但是家教的话一个小时可能就是几十块钱这样子吧，
那我一个月赚个一两钱也就顶天了，
这个收入其实对于一个人在外面，
你要被考，要吃饭，要住宿，
其实是非常非常的不够的。
那个时候你男朋友也不知道你的情况？
对，不知道。
哎，你这很要面子，真的谁都不说。
当时你们俩都在长沙，
你在长沙肯定有很多朋友，
但你谁都没有说，就是自己要压扛，
是的，那你是怎么会想到往代这个方法呢？
一开始应该都是从花碑这种开始的吧，
这是最容易接触到的小额往代，
因为软件天天又导你开花碑，
对，是的。
而且像花碑这种你交外卖啊什么的你都可以去用，
然后它又用的非常的方便，
而且确实是在资金流非常紧张的情况下，
会觉得说，那我先用一下这些，
等我的钱来了，我把它还上就好了。
我相信很多人一开始接触到往代这种小额代，
大部分都是这样的心态。
我当时是觉得，考研假如说我考上了，
那是有一笔讲学金的，
讲学金是可以去覆盖这一部分的还款吗？
然后当时也不会觉得说，
最后能滚出来这么大一个数字。
我觉得听到这里可能很多听众会想说，
哎呀那肯定是你消费水平比较高，
不然的话怎么会欠下这么多钱，
但其实我是觉得很多消费它就是零零散散，
慢慢的滚起来的，
并不是说追求什么奢秘的生活，
或者被消费主义习呢，
我也有的时候真的就是，
你不知不觉间点个外卖也好，付房租也好，
可能说如果你不天天记账的话，
你没有概念，其实很容易会滑到，
一不小心发生，哎怎么这个账单数我这么大？
对，是的，就比如说，
你可能压力非常大的时候，
我点一杯奶茶，
再点一个吃饭的外卖时间20块钱，
然后再点一个甜品，
就是你可能花出去的时候，
只是觉得十几二十块钱，
但最后其实你会发现你这一整天，
可能花了一两百块钱都有可能，
然后慢慢的这种账单就是这么积累起来的，
那从这种零散的借款到欠下十六万，
中间有没有哪个节点，
你其实已经意识到不太对劲了的，
第一次来说，
我还没有意识到不对劲的地方，
只是觉得说，
我能赚到一笔大钱，
尽快的把这个东西给还清，
就可以开启新生活的期待，
就是因为还处在这样一种心态，
才会有了第二次。
诶，你是怎么样在有网袋的情况下还裸辞的？
这也太勇敢了吧？
就是对自己太自信了，
所以我说就是我是一般是自信，一般是压力。
小猫的头高里有写道说，
裸辞的时候其实你的网袋已经欠了十六万了，
之后没工作还不上钱也带不出新的了，
在那个时候你就没有办法只能跟家里坦白。
对，是的，
我裸辞之后，
本来想说我应该还是能比较快的找到工作，
可以覆盖我每个月的，
就是包括这些还款支出和我生活的支出，
那这个危机可能就会随着时间慢慢的能覆盖过去了，
但是比找到工作来得更早的是借不出网袋了。
你还记得是发生在什么时候吗？
我觉得这个应该是你从来没有预料到的情况。
对，是的，在二三年的三月份，
就是在我裸辞的那个月份，
我当时是非常非常的慌，
但是呢，当时是我已经和我男朋友一起住了，
我还要在表面上保持冷静，
什么都没有发生，
你怎么做到的？
你那些因为这个事情这么焦虑了，
你藏着这么大一个秘密。
在这里我还要补充一下，
就是我第二次的时候和我妈妈坦白之前，
我已经和我表姐说了，
然后当时我回家是因为我表姐婚礼，
然后告诉他们之前，
我答应了做我表姐的婚礼主持人，
然后我当天是做完她的婚礼主持人之后，
我再回去跟我妈妈说的这件事情。
所以我觉得我的这种心态也是了不起。
太可怕了。
所以说我也意识到如果我不是找到自己这个问题，
没有卖过去这个坎，
我一定以后遇到什么事情的时候，
我依然可以在心态上扛过去，
但是在解决问题上我一定扛不过去，
所以我觉得非常的幸运。
那你当时是怎么样决定还是跟你妈妈坦白的？
当时是这样子的，
因为她的还款是早上就开始提醒你要还款了吗？
按照以往的操作，
我就是会去别的平台借出来，
然后再还进去，
但是在那天你的额度就已经没有了。
网贷它抽贷了，
你就借不出来任何的钱了。
我有一个问题，
就是你是从哪学到了如何以代养贷的？
我也不知道是从哪里学到的，
我现在想起来应该是有一部分原因，
是因为这些平台借钱太容易了，
而且在你借的时候一般都会有分期嘛。
一开始就是一百多块钱几百块钱，
你觉得这个应该不是什么问题，
可能很快就可以去还上，
但是你没有想过这是在你下一个月，
你的收入还是固定甚至说更少的情况下，
你在还完这一笔钱之后，
你还要生活，生活的钱没有了，
那我又会继续的去借新的，
就这样子借新还旧借新还旧，
然后再加上这些网贷平台的丝滑小连招，
钱非常容易借出来，
那就一个血球就这么滚起来了。
所以你是在回去给你表解当主持人的这个契机，
然后你面对面给你妈妈讲了这个事情？
不是，这个是第二次了。
第一次是刚讲到是从白天他就开始会催你还款嘛，
然后一直到晚上我都没有办法解决这个事情，
然后我就非常非常的害怕，
我就找了一个好朋友，
因为你有这个就是以代养代的这个过程，
你的借款和还款都不会是一天之内的，
一般都是在比如说十二十三十四十五号，
你可能分别都会有几百块钱，
一千多块钱这样子的还款日，
然后当时我的这个朋友就给我借了一千块钱，
把我当天的要还的这个钱给还上了，
然后就建议我尽快的跟家里说这个事情，
我就鼓起勇气，
其实我当时是先跟我爸爸说的，
因为在我爸爸和我妈妈当中，
我爸爸的经济情况是比较好的，
但是他没有任何的犹豫就拒绝了我的请求，
他就是说那我也没有，我帮不了你，怎么办？
然后没有办法，我就跟我妈妈说了，
哎，我有一个问题，
就是你第一次打以后的上岸那个时候是欠了十六万吗？
这个十六万是你预期之后统计出来的数字，
还是你其实一直知道自己往代滚了多少？
不知道，就是在回去解决这个问题，
那是要钱吗？要多少钱？我要算出来？
这个时候才去把所有的账单拉了一遍，
因为其实平时你每个月还钱的体感上来说，
你只知道当月的情况吗？
不太敢算这个钱一共有多少了，不敢去直面它，
而且还在做梦就是觉得说可能明天或者下个月，
如果我能找到一个一万五一个月的工作，
那我一个月还一万块钱也没有什么问题，
就是还是抱着这种心态。
所以等于你和你妈妈一起拉账单统计的这个数字吗？
是我把所有的账单拉出来，
然后给它，一个是要还的钱是什么，
另外一个是他们其实也不敢相信说，
为什么你花了这么这么多钱，
你的这些钱到底花去哪里了？
然后我就把我这几年淘宝、京东、美团，
所有的这些支出我都把它列了下来，
其实回看的话也没有非常多的那种非常大额的消费，
可能顶多也就是几百块钱，一千块钱左右的买衣服或者是什么的。
但是它的频率也是极低极低的，
它不是你每个月都买也不是说怎么怎么样？
对，是的。
不过这里我觉得我自己也是非常的有问题的，
明明在经济情况不是非常好的情况下，
但是我还是要展现出过得还不错的样子吗？
所以像一些正常的买新衣服啊或者是去一些短途的旅行啊，
还是会有发生，就是在维持我自己的人设。
你要维持人设给谁看呢？
我也不知道我要维持给谁看，
但是我就是觉得我要保持这么一种形象，
当任何一个人看到我的时候，
让他觉得我是一个还OK的状态。
我觉得你内心会很恐惧被人瞧不起。
对，是的。
所以第一次坦白之后，
我看小毛的投稿说，
妈妈帮你还了大部分，
然后给你留了两万块钱让你自己还。
然后那个时候你是不是以为这个事情就已经结束了？
对，是的。
而且我在刚还完这个钱的时候，
我不是说我已经找到了一份新的工作吗？
在这份工作开始的时候，
我还每天记账这是我吃饭花了多少钱？
你这个新工作是你之前想象中的那种高薪工作吗？
还是说比之前的要好多少？
嗯，至少比之前的要好了。
第一份工作，
我说出来这个工资你可能都会觉得非常的震惊，
两千八百块钱。
然后第二份工作是每个月有五千左右吧。
所以，薪资其实是上涨了的，
然后如果没有那些店铺或者是意外的话，
其实也是OK的，
仅八八的可以把这个日子给过过去。
我还有一个问题，我要插播一下，
那你这个第一次坦白上岸这一系列的事情，
你男朋友知道吗？当时？
呃，是结束了之后才知道的。
就是找了一个理由说我要回家，
把这个事情解决完了之后才告诉的他。
而且我还是又找了另外一个朋友，
我问他我说我要不要说，
别人建议我还是说，
然后最后我决定说的。
那当时你男朋友的反应是什么？
我记得他和我说他最生气的点是我不告诉他，
但是他气了一下，
就是你惹到我就惹到棉花了，
气了一下也就是气了一下。
因为其实当时他知道的时候这个事情已经解决了嘛，
但是他也不知道还有两万块钱，
我也没有告诉他。
我在想这是不是天赋啊？
你天然就懂得什么叫选择性告知，
就是假话全部说真话不全说。
好像和我小时候的经历也有关系吧，
因为父母离异，
妈妈会问我，
你爸最近和你聊了什么吗？
爸爸也会问我，
你妈妈最近有没有说我不好的地方什么的？
那我作为一个小孩子在中间，
我肯定只会调好的说，
从小就被迫学会了茶叶官司的能力。
嗯，是的，成长环境肯定有一部分的影响，
但是他不是一个充分条件，
就可能别人也像我一样有这样的成长经历，
但是别人也没有做出这个事情，
那肯定还是有其他的原因在。
那我们就回到你刚才说第二次的事情嘛，
就那个时候其实已经找了一个比之前。
更稳定工资更高的工作，
你说你每天还记账，
那为什么又重新开始借？
因为我找的第二份工作他也是会计师搜索嘛，
这个工作的性质就是出差非常非常的多，
基本上一个月都在外面上项目，
我们的项目组是允许两个星期回家一次，
你得自己先去把这个车票给买了，
垫付这些费用，
等到整个项目结束之后才可以进行统一的报销。
在这个垫付的模式下，
那我又有一部分钱是要拿去还款的，
剩下其实也就没有什么钱了，
但是我房租要付啊，
还有除了吃饭以外的支出，
我也是要支出的。
我还欠两万块钱的这个事情，
我也没有和我男朋友说当时，
所以在他看来其实我有五千块钱的收入，
对于这样子的生存模式来说应该是没有什么问题的，
但是我的资金店其实已经非常非常的紧张了，
就又开始了，
认为这只是阶段性的困难，
很快就会渡过去的这种心态，
从用花杯开始，
然后慢慢慢慢的又重复了之前的一个恶性循环。
对，是的。
那第二次又从两万滚到十四十五万的时候，
你的心理状态跟第一次有什么不一样吗？
一模一样的，
再来一次还是一模一样的，
但是不一样的地方是，
我对自己的预期更高了。
啊?
就是因为你在上一份工作跳到下一份工作，
有一个薪资的增长的情况下，
你肯定会预期以后自己还会有更高的收入。
对自己的预期是更高了，
就觉得这次的困难，
我可能比上次自己解决的可能性更大了，
会有这么一种心态在，
就除了这个之外，
我觉得其实都是一样的，
都是因为要面子不说，
然后就一直这么滚血球，
滚得越来越大。
而且中间也遇到了没有想到的一些困难，
就比如说失业。
嗯。
我是从第二份工作离职之后，
进入了一家小微型企业吧，
可以这么说，
进去的时候，
其实他给我开的工资比第二份工作还要再高一些，
但是从我进去的第一个月开始，
他们就拖欠薪资了，
可以说一个月都没有准时发过工资。
太离谱了吧？
是的,
然后当时我是五月份进的这个公司，
做到了八月份的时候，
我妈妈生病了，
首先我回家是需要入费的，
然后在照顾妈妈的这个过程当中，
即使是在有以保的情况下，
那像这种吃饭呢，
交通的这种费用，
他还是需要支出的。
然后我就去问公司说，
可不可以给我发工资？
然后他说，
给我打个特批报告，
当时发了一部分的工资。
我太离谱了，
这不应该是按照法律，
他本来就应该给你的，
居然还要打特批报告。
真的非常的无语。
对,
我感觉第二次以代养代的这个经历，
我觉得他有一点点摸了个偏缝联业语的感觉。
嗯,对。
他们拖欠工资的原因是，
他们自己的资金店是有问题的。
所以当时他们是处在一个供应商，
不断的过来向他们讨债的这个过程，
他们的资金支付安排是每个月做的非常非常非常的细，
而且是别人不来跟你打官司，
可能就没有办法优先拿到他们自己货款的这么一种情况。
对我们员工的工资每个月都是这种拖欠的状态，
我就觉得我在这里待下去不会有什么好的发展。
所以当时就是适用期没有结束，
我就离开了这个公司。
我有一个问题，
那你在长沙和你男朋友一起住的时候，
房租你们俩是要AA的吗？
是的，是的。
是不是你提出来的？
是啊，你都失业了。
你还这么要面子。
很离谱吧？
你们都谈了十几年了，
都是这么亲密的关系。
那互相帮衬这是很正常的事情，
我们不说谁占谁的便宜，
我觉得这跟占便宜没有任何关系，
你们俩应该是彼此最亲近的人。
因为我会觉得说，
有一些我自己应该支出的支出，
别人帮我付了之后，
我可能就要给他一定的对价，
可能是人情，
可能是未来他要我做某件事情的时候，
我不得不答应他，
就是类似这样子的特别害怕欠别人的人情。
其实不是害怕欠别人人情，
我是害怕被别人牵制，
就是很害怕说，
以后我要拒绝别人某个事情的时候，
别人说那我当初怎么怎么怎么样你，
就给你这些帮助，
你这都不帮我，
就是我很害怕这种事情。
理解,
就虽然也有很多道理可以反驳了，
比如说接受别人的善意也是很好的一件事情，
或者是很多人他只是想关心你怎么怎么样，
但是听你聊了这么久，
我觉得我是可以理解你的之前的这种思维方式的，
因为其实是很害怕被伤害被牵制，
因为你之前经历过的跟你很亲密的人，
他们的思维模式和行为方式，
好像都是那个样子的。
对，是的。
所以你后面有写到说，
到你第二次坦白网贷的时候，
你的欠款又已经积攒到14万、15万的这个数字了，
第二次让你决定坦白上岸的契机是什么，
这次应该不是说借不出来了吧？
这次不是，
这次是有一天我发烧了，
然后请假在家睡了一整天，
然后实在是睡不动了，
我就起来看书，看那个被讨厌的勇气，
应该很多人都听说过这本书吧。
我就是看完之后，
我就突然意识到其实我一直活在别人的眼光中，
一直都没有这种被别人讨厌的勇气，
别人不喜欢我，
别人觉得我不好，
那又怎么样呢？
我以前就是把自己一直困在这个想法里面，
然后那一天我看完这本书之后，
我就觉得，
因为有过第一次的经历，
在第二次的时候，
其实我知道这是一个很大很大很大的问题，
我一个人解决不了的问题，
所以当时我就决定说，
我要把这个事情说出来。
那这一次你第一个坦白的人是谁呢？
是我男朋友。
哎，我都不知道，
我很难换位思考，
如果我是他，
我是应该感到开心还是心酸？
开心是这次你第一个选择了我，
坚定的选择了我，
心酸是过去这么长时间你都不告诉我。
嗯,
那他当时的反应你还记得吗？
其实这一次坦白，
我也还是意装到底，
因为我是星期六看的这本书，
然后星期天我们还出去逛街了，
然后逛完街回来，
给自己做了一天的心理准备，
然后晚上才开始和他说的。
那你晚上跟他说的时候，
他肯定觉得非常的震惊，
因为你白天看起来啥事都没有，
突然丢了一个大雷出来。
是的,
这任何人听到都会觉得非常的震惊吧。
这他也没有发脾气。
对，情绪极其稳定。
对，哦，我看到了，
就是你在投稿里有说，
你告诉他之后他的第一反应不是苛责我，
而是带着还在恐惧中的我积极寻找，
解决问题的方案，
甚至还和你一起做了一个PPT来深度剖析。
对,
所以是一个问题解决方案PPT是吗？
对，是的。
这个PPT首先是，
为什么会再次发生这样的问题，
从心理层面，
经济层面，
反正就是从多个方面来剖析，
为什么发生了这样的问题。
然后第二个部分就是，
花了一个时间轴，
来去把我这一段时间发生的事情，
然后这个欠款是如何发生的，
最后累积到我坦白的这个时刻，
一共有多少的金额？
是不是这一次的金额也是，
你跟他坦白之后你们在一起拉的？
对，是的。
哎，你的记账记到哪里去了？
记账就从记不下去，
等那一刻开始就丢掉了。
好的，太真实了。
你继续往下讲。
然后第三部分就是，
如何去解决这个问题，
然后我们还列了方案1234。
最后一部分就是，
我的反思以及他的反思，
这是我男朋友的反思。
他的反思是什么，很好奇。
他的反思是，
他没有及时发现我的这些异常的地方，
也没有督促我和家人进行一个正常的沟通交流。
那当时这个PVT有提过一个行动方案吗？
就比如说下一步怎么办？
有的。
就是列了几个方案1234，
包括了跟朋友借钱，
问妈妈要钱，
还有就是一部分问朋友，
一部分问妈妈，
还有一个方案就是完全逾期，
让他们摧收我自己慢慢还。
列了这几个方案之后，
还把接下来生活的一些预算，
支出预算给做了出来，
去进行了一个我需要多少钱，
以后要怎么生活的蓝图吧，可以说。
我不知道这个问题适不适合问，
就是他没有提出他把钱借给你，
先去把这个签款还上吗？
他没钱呀，他还在读书。
哦，那我觉得这就合理了，
所以你之前会觉得说我已经工作了，
我肯定就即便我的经济状况没有那么好，
但我也要强称一下。
毕竟我是个大人，我是进了社会。
对，我是一个成熟的大人了。
OK，所以第二天你就去跟你妈妈坦白了吗？
是的，因为这次我是主动坦白的嘛，
所以其实还没有到那个缓缓日，
中间还是有一段喘息的时间。
妈妈这次的反应是什么？
当时是这样子的，
我们是把那个PPT做了出来嘛，
我表姐婚礼结束，
然后我男朋友就来我家，
然后再加上那个阿姨。
和那个阿姨的儿子，
就是我从小认的那种干哥哥。
所以你是在一大家子面前做了一个presentation吗？
对，是的。
虽然也没有很一大家子啦，
就是我男朋友，
然后我妈妈，
那个阿姨还有那个哥哥，
那个阿姨的作用就是安抚我妈妈，
那个哥哥的作用就是，
不能让这个局势又回到前一次，
一边倒的骂我的状态，
就是让大家保持一个冷静的状态去理性面对这件事情。
现在回想起来，
你读到被讨厌的勇气那本书的那个经历，
感觉很像电影情节，
就是先烧了一天，
然后实在是睡不下去了，
刚好摸出了这本书，
还把它读完了。
你是读到哪句话或者哪个观点，
就一下子被击中了。
哪一句话不记得了，
但整本书它要表达的意思就是，
你要有这种被别人讨厌的勇气，
就别人怎么看你，
别人怎么对待你，
其实和你自己都没有什么关系。
如果你去觉得别人太你，
或者是因为别人的什么事情导致了，
你认为自己不幸福，
那其实是你自己的选择，
是你觉得说我认为自己很惨，
对你来说是一个安全的状态。
我只是读到，
就是大概是这么一段的地方，
我就觉得，
我好像也是这种状态。
就自己一直认为自己过得很惨，
就是原生家庭也不幸福，
我又已经这么努力了，
我还是一定要在别人面前表现的。
我很好的这种状态，
其实我就是活在别人的评价的眼光中。
但其实别人也未必会评价我，
只是我自己的想象。
你在桃花里说，
原来坦诚的说我不行，
并不会让爱消逝。
这个发现对你来说意味着什么？
意味着我可以，
我以后都可以坦白我不行了。
我以后都可以不用再假装一个完美的人了。
我现在已经又找了一份新的工作了，
已经不是之前的国企了，
跳到了更大的一家公司，
这个事情也是在我坦白完之后，
找到了解决方案，
生活走到正轨之后发生的事情。
就是在我不需要担心这些优得没得的事情的时候，
我就可以花更多的精力放在自我成长上面，
就是意识到自己不行，
那不行又如何呢？
我可以把自己能做的事情做好，
我的好运气它可能自然就会来临。
虽然说从现在的这个节点和自己的同龄人对比，
可能会因为有一些路走的没有那么正，
而比别人发展的慢了一点点，
但是其实把自己的时间放到整个人生的这一个长度来看，
那又如何呢？
两年三年其实也没有太大的不一样的地方，
而且发展的速度它也不是一个线性的，
可能我前几年走的比较慢，
那我后面可能会走的更快，
也不一定，
就是在自己的心态上也会更加的放松一点了吧。
那你现在还会恐惧这个事情再一次发生吗？
还是说你现在彻底把自己的财务状况理顺了，
你觉得这个事情大概率不太会发生了？
我觉得大概率不会再发生了，
但是我觉得这个事情不会再发生的最根本的原因，
好像也不仅仅是我把我的理财给理顺了，
还是因为我放下了我的面子。
我觉得这是你头高里我特别喜欢的一段，
就是你说你开始主动和朋友和妈妈说，
我没有能力帮你买这个，
我现在没钱和你一起去吃这顿昂贵的漂亮饭，
你现在可以接纳不完美的自己，
然后对当下的财富和生活做更好的规划，
我觉得这个就特别棒了。
是的，我会觉得。
对，因为你有提到说，
你听到我跟肖宇老师录的那期命运杀猪盘，
你就立刻会想到自己。
其实这一期节目呢，也是我男朋友先听，
然后他听了之后，他推荐给我说，
我一定要听这一期节目，
然后听完了之后，我就觉得，
这说的不就是我吗？
如果你没有找到自己的那个杀猪盘，
你就会在一次又一次面临同样的问题的时候做同样的选择，
那最后还是回到同样的起点，
就像我去接网贷的这个事情，
我第一次坦白了，
但是其实并没有解决最根本的矛盾，
没有去放下我的面子，
接纳自己的不完美，
也没有办法向身边的人求助，
就是因为当时没有把这个问题去解决了，
所以导致了我第二次还是跳进了这个火坑。
嗯，你在投稿里有写道说，
你在年初把勇敢定为了你的年度关键死，
但后来你觉得坦诚这个词更贴切，
这是为什么呢？
一开始我会觉得说，
把自己的不完美坦露给别人是一种勇气，
但是我现在觉得其实不是勇气而是坦诚，
就是把你原本是什么样子展现出来，
它就是一个理所应当的事情，
它不是一个需要勇气的事情，
这是展现最真实的自己，
可能有的时候能让你更好的和身边的人相处吧。
那如果未来再遇到困难，
你希望自己第一步做什么？
第一步，我先自己分析，
这个困难等级是什么？
是我自己能解决的问题，
还是我自己不能解决的问题？
我自己没有办法解决，
就去积极地找身边的援助，
包括我男朋友啊，家里人啊，朋友啊，
但此时此刻你还会担心，
如果我接受了他的帮助，
我会受到他的牵制，
你现在还会这么想吗？
还会。
我怎么感觉你很像那种，
我捡回来的猫咪，
就是那个戒备心超级无敌的众？
啊，我们家有一只猫咪就是这样子，
它是流浪的，
然后被别人捡回去了，
我们把它收养了，
它一开始回到家的时候，
真的是帮帮打人，
在它的周围，
它就会伸出爪子打你，
养了它又两三年了吧，
它现在已经可以开始翻肚子了。
有一种京城所致今时未开的感情？
对，是的。
那我觉得这个可能也不急，
也许再过一段时间，
你可能慢慢的自己回头看会发现说，
哎，好像我也没有那么警惕这件事情了，
对他人的善意你也可以，
很有安全感的接受了。
对，我觉得一方面，
我自己在未来变得更强大的时候，
可能我自己能给自己的安全感会更足，
另一方面就是在和自己的一些亲密的人相处的过程中，
你坦露自己的不完美，
坦露自己的不优秀，
也能接受到对方的爱意的时候，
也会给你很大的安全感。
在这种安全感的情况下，
可能就会变得越来越能够做一个更坦承的人吧，
能更容易接受别人善意的人。
如果有年轻人正在靠借贷，隐瞒，
硬撑来维持体面，
你想和他们说什么？
我想和他们说，
你们不要奢望自己可以解决这个事情，
那是你一定解决不了的问题。
既然你的生活都需要去靠借这么大一笔网贷来维持的话，
那你短时间之内绝对没有办法解决这个问题。
所以我给他们的建议，
第一个就是首先跟自己信任的人，
包括家里人和朋友去坦白这个事情。
如果他们能够帮你的话，
那是最好的，
把这个事情一次性解决清楚，
并且要找到自己为什么会做这种借网贷来生活的根本原因。
你要把这个找到，
然后去把这个根本的问题给解决掉，
给自己做个PPT。
对，可以做一个PPT，
深度剖析自己的原因。
然后如果说你求助的人没有办法去帮助你的话，
那你就余期吧。
其实大部分人不敢余期，
就是怕会被暴通巡路，
就是怕面子嘛，
黑真信。
我觉得好像更多人是怕面子，
真信都是排在比较后面的地方，
你肯定是不想让别人知道自己这个事情，
你才害怕这件事情。
所以呢，就是放下你们的面子，
去接受自己做过这样一件蠢事，
把自己的一个财务情况给梳理好，
能还多少就还多少。
我还有最后一个想问你的问题，
就是当你慢慢的放下了用面子来定义自己的价值感之后，
那还有什么在支撑你的价值感呢？
对，你现在会怎么定义自己？
或者是什么会让你觉得充满力量，觉得很值得？
我觉得我好好的过好每一天，
就已经可以让我非常的有力量了。
我觉得我现在已经在一家还不错的公司，
然后自己也没有放弃在事业上和学习上的进步，
然后在生活上也有自己给自己建立的一些SOP，
给自己建立的秩序，
就是做完这些事情之后，
你整个人就不会觉得非常的空虚。
不会自我怀疑，也不会内行。
对,
就像你此刻展现在我面前就是非常有活力的样子。
嗯，是的。
好呀，那再次感谢小毛的分享，谢谢你。
然后呢，也祝愿你之后一切顺利，
虽然晚了几天，
但还是祝你28岁生日快乐。
谢谢雨白。
听完小毛的故事，
我会觉得他和我们平时在网上看到的。
很多负债商案的故事不太一样。
他不是一个只要坦白，
爱并不会消失的温馨故事，
但他也不是一个可以简单的用。
这个人真是不负责任来概括的故事。
如果只是停留在责备这一步，
我们就很难理解，
一个人为什么会一次次用同样的方式。
把自己推到那个深坑里面去。
我觉得小毛这个故事给我们最重要的提醒，
是不要用借贷去维持一个。
我过得还不错的样子，
也不要心存幻想，
觉得之后我一定会突然赚到一笔大钱，
把今天的问题全部盖过去。
很多时候债务就是在这种幻想里。
一点一点滚大的。
如果你已经发现自己在靠消费贷、
网贷或者以贷养贷来维持生活，
小毛最后的那句提醒其实很重要，
不要再自己一个人硬扛了，
先把账算清楚，
告诉一个你真正信任的人，
尽快停止这样的生活，
避免债务继续越滚越大。
而对小毛来说，
坦白也不是故事的结尾，
后来真正发生变化的，
是他终于开始放下，
那个我必须看起来过得很好的执念。
他开始承认自己也会有解决不了的问题，
也需要别人的帮助。
他也开始发现，求助不等于失败，
不完美也不等于不值得被爱。
小毛也开始放下幻想，
承担责任、努力工作，
每个月认真的存钱、还钱，
努力争取在未来回报身边所有人的善意。
我觉得这是他真正走出同一个陷阱的开始。
接下来这位听有盖饭的故事，
也许很多这两年毕业求职过的年轻朋友会很有共鸣。
他是2024年的文科毕业生，
大学几年赶上风笑和网课，
到了求职的时候，简历上几乎没有什么实习经历。
那段时间他特别焦虑，
每天做的事情就是改简历、
投简历、面试、晚上睡也睡不好。
那个时候，他几乎把自己的价值。
全部绑在找到一份工作这件事情上，
好像只要还没有offer，
自己之前所有的选择都会变成笑话，
未来也无法安定下来。
但盖饭的故事不只是在讲求职焦虑，
他后来慢慢发现，
当一个人的生活里只剩下一件看起来最重要最紧急的事情之后，
其他很多东西会慢慢被挤到旁边。
接下来让我们听听盖饭的故事。
大家好，我叫盖饭，
我现在是一名货联网大厂的女工。
平时会去运动，
然后喜欢画画，
还喜欢摄影，还喜欢旅行，
还喜欢看书和听播客，
当然这些小酒馆是我非常最常听的播客，
没有之一。
谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。
因为看你的投稿的时候就感觉到你是一个很有感受力的人嘛，
就像你前面说的，
你有很多的爱好，
但从毕业积到正式工作，
这些原本很鲜活的部分，
好像都被求职和工作一点点挤到了边上。
因为盖饭在投稿里有写说，
自己之前因为工作压力，
然后身体出了一些状况，
结果得一个人去做手术。
但是在做完手术那一天，
你说你久违的在工作日看到了落日，
就我觉得那个画面对我的冲击很强烈，
就好像在那一刻你突然意识到，
自己确实得到了不错的工作，
不错的薪水，
但也失去了很多东西。
是，其实那个画面对我的冲击也是蛮大的，
因为我当时做手术的那个医院，
他就在西湖附近。
做完手术出来，
他是个菊马手术嘛，
然后买完之后那个马药还没过。
我就想着那我去西湖边走一走，
我就在那个长椅上坐下，
我就发现那天，
等日落十分的阳光洒在西湖的湖面上，
湖面上就波光凌凌，
然后会有那种成对的渊药，
以及野鸭子在湖面上飘着，
然后远处就是那个群山，
然后进出的话就是西湖边会有很多的树，
然后那个树上会有很多小松鼠，
然后那个小松鼠就是上算下跳的，
感觉很活泼，
然后周围的话会有很多老年人在那里进行，
老年活动就唱歌啊什么的。
我就在那里做了大概十几二十分钟，
然后我就想啊原来工作日的午后也是如此的美好。
那个时候大概是几点？
应该是五六点的样子。
那平时工作日这个点的时候你都在干嘛？
在准备结束下午的工作，
然后去吃饭，
然后再开起晚上的工作是吗？
是的，范围很重的一级。
因为你在脱稿里说你当时坐在湖边，
看着这些人来人往，
感觉到自己虽然得到了光纤的工作和还不错的薪水，
但好像失去了很多更重要的东西，
你那天想到的自己失去的东西具体是什么呢？
首先最明显的就是阳光，
我确实上班之后我很少能够见到阳光，
因为我上班的时候，
他那个太阳可能还没出来，
然后我下班的时候呢太阳已经落下去了，
起次的话我就能感觉到上班之后，
确实我的感受力是变差了。
我会觉得我没有办法，
因为一些无关紧要的事情停下来住足，
欣赏一下，
我只能很形色匆匆的，
比如说赶着去通勤，
然后看着表，看自己是不是要迟到了，
然后晚上下班之后呢，
我也不想在路上过多的停留，
因为那个时候那个瞬间我是刚刚做完手术嘛，
我就会觉得哎，有时候没有工作的话，
说不定就不用手术了，
确实健康上也是失去了蛮多。
所以其实是从毕业季的时候就开始了嘛，
因为那个时候比较焦虑或者压力大。
嗯，是的，
因为我们是从高三的时候就开始遇到疫情嘛，
上了大学之后基本上大一到大三一直在风笑，
其实对于我们而言实习的机会，
就现下实习的机会会比较少一些，
然后在现在的这个求职环境下，
你的实习经历比较不丰富的话，
其实求职是比较困难的，
特别是对于文科生来说，
另一方面就是来自家里的压力也会比较大，
这个就要说到一些老生常谈的原生家庭的问题。
嗯，就是我家的情况呢，
就是概括来讲，
就是不负责任的爸，
情绪不稳定的妈，
破碎的他，
治理破碎的家，
和不知所措的我，
大概就这么一个构造，
然后呢，
我从小的话，
我妈妈确实把我照顾得很好，
她会每天就是很精心的去准备我的餐食，
然后照顾我的饮食起居，
同时兼顾她自己的工作，
真的是非常非常负责，
很尽责的妈妈，
但是她在情感上可能会更依赖我一点，
后来我在心理学上就看到一个词叫亲直化，
我觉得挺能概括我妈妈的这种亲子模式的颠倒的。
就比如说在一些生活上的细节，
她会管我每天吃什么，
然后几点睡，
但是在一些人生的大事上，
比如说高中学问学理，
我跟她说我应该学问还是学理，
我感觉好像更喜欢且擅长文科一点，
但是好像都听说李科更好找工作，
你怎么看呢？
她就说我怎么知道你自己决定，
所以可能到了毕业季的时候，
我就习惯性的还是自己做这种比较重大的决定了。
所以包括像你在投稿里也说，
你主动减少了和家人和朋友的联系，
当然一方面是确实咱妈也拍不上用场，
然后另外我看到你写说，
你也很害怕看到同龄的朋友已经拥有了自己的出路，
然后再加上论文进展也不是很顺利，
就整个人就处在非常焦虑的状态。
是的，就是我的身边的朋友，
然后那个时候大家好像手里都有一个目标，
有一件要做的事情在做，
好像只有我一天看起来很忙，
但不要再干嘛，
所以我那个时候心里压力就会比较大一些，
那个时候我就觉得如果找不到工作，
那我的人生就完蛋了呀，
然后当时会把事情给灾难化想象，
就觉得找不到工作的话，
我该怎么办？
我还得继续渴老吗？
然后如果渴老的话，
那不是要天天跟家里吵架，
然后我感觉压力很大。
当然你现在回头看会觉得自己那个时候很钻牛角尖，
但是身处其中其实你很难跳出来。
是的，因为在那个环境下，
比如说你有时候偶尔跟朋友聊天，
就在说今天这个面试遇到一个很奇葩的面试官，
然后你打开QQ群发现辅导员老师就在群里转发那种什么叉叉公司招聘信息，
然后你打开家里的群就发现家里人说，
你那个工作找得怎么样了呀？
你有没有想过要不要去考个公务员啊？
然后你感觉整个环境也是被笼罩在这种氛围之下很难抽离出来。
就是你周边的环境没有任何一处，
它是在给你提供支持感的，都是在给你施加压力的。
然后包括你写到说有一天你突然觉得很累，
开始不再疯狂投减力，变成有面试就面，
没有就在出租屋里躺，
就是什么契机让你突然就松掉了。
让我松掉的契机其实就是那个时候到了春节了嘛，
然后春节我就想着那你总得回家过年呀，
对吧，然后我就回家了。
回家之后呢，见到高中时期的很好朋友，
然后就感觉见面了之后你会有一种活在当下的感觉，
就是你会感觉啊，原来我的朋友都在身边，
然后原来你的生活中除了找工作，除了毕业，
你还可以有很多朋友的关爱，
加上那个时候回到家确实一般来讲回家前几天你是不会跟家里吵架的嘛。
大过年的？
对，然后那几天这还是蛮高兴的。
我就觉得好像找不找工作也没有那么重要，
这还是蛮开心。
我就感觉好像要松下来你的生活也没有崩塌嘛，
那你是不是可以考虑把这种状态延续下去呢？
然后到了春节的时候就是过年，
然后过年就回到外婆家，
然后外婆的话对我来说是非常非常重要的一个人，
因为我的爷爷奶奶还有我的外公都去世的比较早，
基本上就从小到大都是跟外婆最亲嘛。
对我来讲其实他承担了一部分，
本来应该是由我爸爸妈妈给到我的一些关爱的这个角色，
就是他在我成长过程中他会成为我的一个避风港，
会给到我一些很纯粹的爱，
让我感觉就是无论我在外面需要自己知论到一种什么程度，
但是我在他面前我可以一直做一个小孩子，
我一直是他就是最疼爱的孙女的这种感觉。
所以那个时候回家感觉就是在和亲人朋友的这种相处当中，
我慢慢的放松下来了，就没有那么紧绷。
后面该饭就有写道说，
当自己抱着一个很松弛的心态去投简历，
然后去面试，
然后反而很顺利的拿到了奥夫，
然后生活状态也慢慢好起来了。
然后是我记得是应该是二月吧，
春节回来可能是几二十天，
有一天我就打开邮箱，
发现有一条消息说，
这个邀请你下周一面试，
然后我就去面了，
然后面的时候呢，
一面感觉自己还比较紧张，
还说错了一些，
那个时候我面完没有抱太大期待。
结果没想到就这么顺利的拿到了奥夫。
对，是的，
所以拿到的时候还是蛮惊讶的，
然后当时我就，
就拿到工作了，
然后第一时间就跟家里说，
然后我妈妈知道之后，
她终于可以放心地说，
那你不考公务员确实是对的。
所以等于拿到奥夫到毕业典礼之前，
那两个月就属于毕业前的一个什么，
蜜月期，
就是可以吃吃喝喝玩玩做自己喜欢的事情。
对啊,
我觉得超开心。
那是什么样的一个契机，
会让你在毕业典礼之前突然想回家一趟？
我觉得有的时候真的就是明明之中自有天意。
当时其实我是这样想的，
就是高考结束之后呢，
我一直没有回高中去看过我的班主任，
想那我就抽个几天时间回家看看，
然后顺便去约以前的同学一起去看看我的高中班主任。
所以那个时候我就是头一天，
我脑子里突然一下蹦出了这样的一个念头，
第二天我就买第二天的票，
然后我就回了，
但回家之后我就发现很诡异，
那天我到家之后就发现家里没人，
我就想那他们可能出去了吧，
然后我就给他们发消息，
我说我提前回来了，
惊不惊喜，
意不意外，
然后我说晚上一起吃饭，
结果我妈过了很久才回我消息，
她说你今天晚上自己吃饱，
然后她说我在外面有点事，
我说我当时还在想什么事呢，
到了晚上的时候我就一个人吃完饭回家，
我妈那个时候也回家了，
到了第二天，
就是我感觉就是度过了非常非常正常且平凡的一天，
然后回家之后呢我就想着好久没有练琴了，
我就练一下琴吧，
我练了琴之后呢我就坐在那个琴凳上，
然后我把那个谱关上，
然后我妈突然就坐在旁边，
她说你明天什么安排呀，
我说我没有什么安排呀，
我说明天不是周日吗，
之前周日不是都要去外婆家看过外婆吗，
那明天就去看外婆吗，
然后她就突然一下沉默了，
然后我一回头发现她哭了，
我心里就割灯一下，
她就跟我说大概就三月份的时候，
我外婆感觉身体不太舒服就去检查，
检查出来呢就发现是未来晚期，
然后因为她们担心我的状态也不好，
所以就一直瞒着我没有告诉我，
然后就在最近外婆她已经就是重症了，
就住到医院里去了，
并且就是一时也不太清醒，
然后前一天我妈妈她不在，
是因为她去医院照顾外婆了，
我当时就觉得老天在跟我开一个非常非常大的玩笑，
因为过年的时候外婆还非常的，
起码表现出来很健康，
还能给你非常正常的聊天，
对，就是我外婆80多岁了嘛，
但是她一直是那种就是精神绝术的那种形象，
而且她身体非常的好，
她之前就是跟她的那些朋友去欧洲旅行什么的，
那个时候都已经快80岁了，
我记得是她80刚出头的时候吧，
有一些她家里灯泡坏了，
然后我们就说要不回去帮你修一下，
就和她说不用不用，
下一次去看她的时候发现灯泡坏好，
我们就问她说，
你找工人来帮你修了，
她说没有，
她自己拿梯子爬上去换的，
太鸟了，
对,
就她一直是身体很好的那种形象，
结果我就回去找到了一个工作，
然后达了个变，
怎么回来就变天了，
我当时就感觉我整个人都蒙掉了，
谁曾想就在我妈妈跟我坦白的当天晚上，
我舅舅她就打电话过来说，
感觉外婆状态不太好，
她说你赶紧过来吧，
然后我们就赶紧收拾东西过去，
过去的时候呢，
我一推开那个病房就发现，
她已经非常非常的虚弱的躺在那个病床上，
然后那个整个病床的那个病房也很逼色，
感觉采光或者是通风什么的也不是很好，
后来我就过去我就握住外婆的手，
就发现她的手就是很凉很凉，
家里的其他的人就说你快看是谁来了，
然后就是我回来了，
然后外婆她本来是没有什么反应的，
听到大家说话之后，
她就退下又反应了，
还叫了我的名字，
然后我当时就崩不住了，
我就一个抱哭，
那个时候已经晚上了隔壁床的那个奶奶，
她都已经睡觉了，
但我那个时候就已经顾不上什么素质了，
我就直接在那抱哭超大声，
我说我找到工作了，我要毕业了，
然后就我回来看你了，
但是你怎么生病了呀，
然后什么的确实很崩溃，
在那吼吼打哭，
然后家里可能看到我这样哭，
他们自己本身情绪也一直是在一个紧崩的状态下，
然后在我这么一哭呢，
他们那根鞋也松了，
他们也开始抱哭，
整个病房就是一幅那种电视距离常见的画面，
过了一段时间十几二十分钟，
医生就说他的状态其实还是比较稳定的，
就没有变坏，
说你们不然家属就先回去呗，
然后我就跟我妈回去了，
结果刚到家，
然后又打电话，
我们又回到了医院，
就感觉这一切发生的太快了，
对,
后来我差不多就是在第二次回到医院的时候，
我就坐在那个凳子上，
非常安静，
病房里，
我就感觉从悲伤中回过了一点点，
我就有点生气，
我就在想为什么家里人不告诉我呢，
就这么大的事儿，
你是气他们还是气自己，
我先是气他们，
然后我可能是等到之后，
就是把之后的一些全部的事情处理完之后，
我回过头来想，
整个那段时间的状态，
我觉得其实是我自己，
我应该怪我自己，
因为我明明知道我，
妈妈她是抗压能力比较差的人，
然后我那个时候经常跟她说我压力很大，
给她这么大的压力，
然后她本身自己也在背负着外婆这边生病的压力，
就是双重压力之下，
她肯定觉得她不愿意再给我增加心理负担，
所以她不告诉我，
但是在当时在病房的那个当下，
我是很生气的，
我觉得家里这么多人一个都不告诉我，
什么意思呢？
因为小的时候我记得我看新闻，
就是会有那种比如高考的时候，
有一些他的爷爷奶奶或者是外公外婆生重病了，
或者是去设家里派影响他的高考，
就不告诉他这种社会新闻，
但是我就没有想到社会新闻竟然是我自己，
就是他们竟然真的不告诉我，
而且一直到这种程度都不告诉我，
那如果我没有，
如果你没有心血来乘，
我没有想要回来看老师，
对啊,
那我就永远的错过了，
因为就在我去医院的那天当天的晚上凌晨，
我外婆就去设了，
我整个人就是一方面是觉得很惊讶，
就是会觉得这个世界真的很神奇，
另一方面，
我感觉是接受了一场非常非常刻骨明星的。
死亡教育和人格成长的教育，
那在这之后给外婆办后室的那几天你是怎么度过的，
其实这么大的悲痛下，
还要正常形式其实对一个人来说非常的艰难，
其实那个时候，
我感觉我反而没有很强烈的情绪，
就是我只在病床前以及刚得知这个消息的时候，
我坐在那个行灯上哭过两次，
然后我就没有再怎么很崩溃的哭过了，
因为我发现说家里因为我妈妈也好，
舅舅他们也好，
就是他们年纪也比较大了，
那我反正要毕业了，
也是一个即将步入社会的这么一个人，
也是成年人了，
我觉得我应该去承担起这个责任，
所以你主动承担了很多，
对，就是基本上那些所有的一些手续啊，
然后除了医院这块，
比如说去殡医馆啊，
之后再去邻院，
这所有的基本上都是我去完成的，
所以就在整个这个过程当中，
我感觉就是事情一件接一件的时候，
你反而不会去，
没有时间给你难过，
你得赶紧把这些事情都办妥了，
到了那个殡医馆之后，
我还有一件事情对我冲击蛮大的，
就是我其实在大学四年，
我一直觉得我学的专业没有什么用，
但是到了那个殡医馆的时候，
就是那个工作人员掏出了一本册子，
他说这个是一本晚连，
他说你看一下，
就是要给你们家的老人选一幅，
我打开，我就逐一翻阅，
我就发现，
哦，原来我学的这些，
他可以用在这种时候，
他是希望你去找一条和你的家人。
最贴近的这么一条晚连，
选了之后他给你拿来对应的，
然后把它布置上去，
然后当时我就翻阅了之后，
选了一条我觉得和我外婆，
他这种一直以来很坚韧，
然后很自强不息的这样一个性格的女性，
很贴切的一条晚连，
我当时觉得，
我的专业也是派上了一点点小小的用途。
在这一刻，
汉语言文学意义生回，
闪闪发光。
是的。
可这个事情发生的时候，
你会不会突然一下子觉得，
自己之前尤其是毕业绩，
那么执着于找到一份好工作，
那个执念好像，
一下子显得没有那么有价值了？
非常的无足轻重，
可以说是。
就如果我早知道会这样的话，
我一定就不会把所有的，
这种价值都绑定在找工作这件事情上。
我当时就觉得说，
确实是那个时候把所有的这些，
人生的支点绑定在一件事情上，
所以会导致一旦这个支点，
它是虚无飘渺的，
它没有一个定数，
你就心里面就是会很混乱，
没有一个秩序。
可是后来，
当你完全进入工作之后，
好像工作又占据了你的全身心，
然后就然后一步一步导致了，
那个在西湖边享受阳光的下午，
你会觉得自己有点重蹈覆辙的感觉吗？
会有一点，
但我觉得我现在其实拥有了在这种混乱，
或者是说没有秩序的生活当中搭建起秩序的能力。
所以我会知道说我现在工作忙，
那工作忙这件事情是我凭我一己之力，
暂时是没有办法改变的。
那我能够把握的是什么？
比如说，
我是不是可以在能力范围内保持比较健康的饮食，
然后你在业余时间的时候呢，
既然你的业余时间已经被工作占据了一部分，
那你剩下一部分是不是就刷一点手机，
干一点真正可以自扬你内心的事情，
然后去做你真正喜欢做的事情。
我觉得就是在这样的一个过程中，
我感觉又把自己重新的升级了一下。
所以我感觉现在的状态对比起毕业季那段时间，
应该是更好了一些。
那你先会提高，比如说跟家里人沟通的频率吗？
会，我会主动就是给家里人打电话，
然后发消息，
包括说我有主动的去修复一些我以前很看重的一些远身家庭，
我觉得这个东西一直是我的指念嘛。
但是我会主动的比如说给我爸约体检，
然后跟他联系，跟他聊天，分享下很多日常之类的。
然后包括跟妈妈也是我又敞开心肺的聊了很多，
然后也发现妈妈其实现在就是她的人生，
可能是已经经过那个播风了，
她在往下走，而我是一个在往上走的上升的阶段。
然后有很多事情其实没有必要太跟她太执着，
然后一直在争论，
就没有必要那么较真。
对，没有必要那么较真，
就是大家只要互相陪伴就好了。
而且我之前应该是在哪里看到的吧？
就是说你可以算一下，
就你和家人见面的次数还有多少次。
不是我们播客吗？
你医生的财富啊？
啊对，应该就是。
然后我当时我记得就是我去算了一下，
我就感觉确实那是珍惜吧，珍惜当下。
因为外婆这件事情的时候我确实也在想说，
你之前是不是觉得你们还有很长很长的时间，
还有很多很多次可以见面的机会。
所以你每次见面的时候，
你都没有把注意力放在当下，
你可能一边在跟她聊天，
你一边在玩手机。
但直到真正失去的时候，
你发现原来那些看似不起眼的瞬间，
是这么的宝贵，是这么的珍贵。
如果此时此刻有一个听众，
他可能也是在毕业季，
然后在为Alpha或者是未来的出路焦虑，
你有什么想跟他说的吗？
我感觉干货上，
因为我自己的求职经历也是，
不是特别具有代表性吧。
我感觉更多可能是心态调整上。
我觉得在这个阶段，
人生处于一个非常混乱，
很混沌的一个时期。
那这个时期其实我觉得，
保持内心的秩序还是蛮重要的。
首先我觉得最重要的一点就是，
你的整个生活，
它不可以只有一个指点。
比如说它把一段关系看得很重要，
或者是把一份工作看得很重要。
那如果一旦这件事情，
它出现了一些披露，
那整个人生就很容易崩塌。
懂了，干货老师是教我们，
鸡蛋不能放在一个篮子里。
对，就鸡蛋不可以放在一个篮子里。
那你现在戏属的话，
现在你的价值感这个鸡蛋放在了多少个篮子里？
让我来数一下。
首先工作肯定是一部分，
然后其次的话，
是我的兴趣爱好，
给到我很多的振反愧。
然后另一部分的话，
就是我感觉在我的日常的生活，
我觉得把我的身体养好了。
然后另一方面我觉得是人际关系上，
就是我在这两年，
有主动的去多跟朋友们联系见面，
然后多跟家人就见面也好，
聊天也好，
我感觉就是在他们身上，
我能够收获到不一样的爱，
然后我感觉他们也把一部分的我给撑起来了。
然后还有一部分的话，
我觉得就是自我提升跟学习这一块，
就是当你处在一种不断向上的这个状态里的时候，
其实你每天都很充实，
你感觉有做不完的事想要去做，
那这个时候其实你就没有功夫去瞎想你的人生，
也就不会疯他。
哎，我怎么感觉你这讲的，
完全就是之前我们节目里讲的那个无众财富嘛，
就是物质，心理，社交，健康，
不愧是你，
因为该发老奖特别好，
因为真的很重要。
那如果假如现在外婆能够听到你现在的生活和你的话，
你最希望能跟她讲什么呢？
我其实这个问题我每次在过年的时候回去，
就是会去给她那个草木的时候嘛，
我都会都会想一下。
今年我可能就想分享的就是我现在把自己照顾的挺好的，
我有在调整自己的作息，
尽量不要熬夜，
然后每天吃饭有好好吃饭，
睡觉有好好睡觉，
去探索了很多新的地方，
有了很多新的人生体验。
我就想告诉她说，
我现在过得很好，
你放心，
就是我再也不会像以前那么焦虑，
那么迷茫，
那么无错了，
就我已经是一个大人了。
为我骄傲吧。
我觉得她一定会的，
而且我觉得她能够从你的状态能感受到。
你就在变得越来越好，
也在逐渐的过一种，
你越来越爱自己的这样的一个生活。
所以你一定要打起精神来。
好。
哎呀，那谢谢盖范，
谢谢你和我们分享，
感谢。
盖范讲到最后，
其实有一个很朴素，
但很重要的提醒，
一个人的生活，
不能只靠一个支点撑着，
毕业绩的时候，
她把自己的价值，
几乎都绑在找工作这件事情上，
后来真的进入工作，
又发现工作可以继续占据一个人的身体，
时间和全部的感受力。
直到外婆离开，
她才更深的意识到，
很多事物不会永远在原地等待我们。
家人、老师、朋友、健康、爱好，
那些平时看起来没有那么紧急的事情，
其实也在一点点构成我们是谁，
我们对自身价值的认知。
所以后来，
该犯选择重新把这些东西捡回来，
运动、看书、画画、和朋友见面，
主动跟家人联系，
也更认真的照顾自己的身体。
接下来这位听友老李的故事，
也和选择有关，
只不过在他的故事里，
选择这个问题是在很久之后才浮现出来的。
老李本科在美国留学，
读书的时候家里发生变故，
他靠在当地做外卖生意，
把自己的生活撑了下来，
当时一个月最多能赚三千美元。
可毕业回国之后，
他先回到家乡的小县城，
月薪以下子掉到了三千块，
之后他到了上海，
继续做自己喜欢的餐饮行业，
从一开始的结局，
到攒下第一个两万，
第一个二十万，
再到第一个一百万。
如果只看这些数字变化，
这好像是一个很标准的逆袭故事。
可到了二零二五年，
老李突然开始问自己，
我一直在努力往前走，
也一直在解决问题，
可是这条路到底有多少是我自己选的呢？
接下来，我们就来听听老李的故事。
首先要先谢谢你给我们投稿，
我觉得现在应该请你来介绍一下自己。
好呀，好呀，我简单介绍一下，
我叫老李，我是97年的，
然后我大学时期是在美国，
还有中立大学留学，
然后在18年底的时候毕业回到国。
我从二零年开始一直在上海工作，
从事餐饮行业，
在二零二五年四月的时候结束了这份工作，
同年我在十月的时候，
结束了在上海接近五年的生活，
搬回了自己从小成长的城市成都，
在成都开始生活。
你投稿里有一段我很好奇，
你说你很喜欢张肖宇老实录的那些小酒馆，
命运会一直给你出同样的题目，
直到给出不同的答案。
你说自己好像从来没有一次，
是权然听从内心给出答案并且行动。
直到去年，
你第一次决定把自己交给生命之流回到起点去迎接未知。
所以我想先从这里聊起，
你是从什么时候意识到自己过去很多重要的人生选择，
好像都不是自己去做的。
对，之所以张肖宇老实那期对我来说这么重要，
是因为当他说了，
就是说每个人都读属于自己的一款命运杀出盘的时候，
一直在回问自己，
什么是我的命运杀出盘。
然后那个时候我的第一个答案就是说，
我好像从来就是从我有积极开始，
我从来没有对自己的人生做过任何一个主动的选择。
我读书的时候要出国的决定是我妈做的。
我出国选了大学，
其实我只是上学老师给了我一些选择，
然后他给了一个综合中最好的一个相对好的一个学校，
因为我从来没有对我的陆区的学校做过任何一次详细的调查，
他们在哪个州我陆学是什么专业，
我要去到的学校它是什么样的。
所以连这个专业都不是你自己选的吗？
对，连专业都不说，
我的大学陆区进入的专业是Linguistic与研学，
非常非常偏的学科，
我后面回看我才知道，
可能这个专业就是当时我升学老师为了可以录到这个学校而走的一个方式去录去的。
可是我觉得他这样很不负责任，
完全不管你的死活，不管你擅长什么喜欢什么，
但这个可以让他的业绩很漂亮，
我有多少学生升到了多么多么好的大学。
对，对，但是现在回看其实也并非一个怎么说的不好，
就是我确实进入到了一个我的成绩能到的最好的学校了。
这是里面有运气的成分，
但他还是有点不负责任。
对，是的，然后我的大学毕业之后，
我并没有因为自己有归号好自己的人生，
我到底是要继续读研究生，
我要待在美国还是我要回到国内，
我当时是因为家里有了变故，
我不得不回到国内而回到国内的。
这个可以讲吗？
就是你在投稿里有说因为留学时家里有了变故，
是的，你就自己做餐饮赚生活费，
是的，是的，
你是在美国的时候就开始做了，
还是说回国了之后才开始？
我从大一的时候就开始了，
当时的时候，
大一才18岁？
对，我在美国做了一个自己的小龙虾的外卖，
就像于是自己做小龙虾，
然后类似于现在恶论么的逻辑，
然后给所有的各伦不当地的留学生跟华人给他们发菜单，
然后他们可以微信点单，
然后我已经做完，
然后我会自己开车，
然后一家一家配送给他们。
当时只是开始做的原因是因为。
我们觉得我们各伦不当地12点之后就没有任何一个夜宵可以吃了，
然后因为我们家一直都是做生意的嘛，
而Rumorize下如果有这样一个机会和共续关系的一个施衡，
然后我就跟我程度的朋友说，
我想做个小龙虾，
我们试试吧，
然后我说我想做小龙虾，
我的地步是那我去哪儿买虾呢？
我就开始往上搜，
我发现美国路易莎那州他专门卖小龙虾，
就是活虾，
我就去Amazon上网购。
对，就是美国南部风味他也会做这种，
他们也会吃小龙虾，
但它是那种有点黑人南部口味的那种，
对对对，手抓海鲜的那种感觉，
对对对对，
当时只是有这个样一个想法，
然后我们甚至没有非常完整的菜单，
我让我的程度的朋友写了一个文案，
我订了小龙虾我们就直接开始了，
开始的时候我从学生宿舍楼底下的公共食堂开始做起，
到后面因为可能会占用别人的食堂吧，
然后我去向学长借他们家的厨房，
我说我过来晚饭的话我给你一起带着做了，
你可不可以让我用一下你的厨房，
我半夜做晚，
然后自己把我做的放冰箱，
然后我自己再回宿舍睡觉，
这个是大义一切的开始，
那个时候只是出于一个，
那个时候是兴趣，
对我喜欢做饭，
其实是我们觉得有商机可以稍微做一下，
但直到大二开始的时候，
那是2017年那个时候的变故发生，
就是当有一天我要生活费的时候，
我发现家里没有说为什么，
家里只是没有给我打生活费了，
然后我慢慢发现就可能接连的一个月两个月之后就都没有生活费了，
然后我好像意识到了什么，
但是我家里也从来不跟我说这些，
那你跟爸妈聊天的时候他们也不会提这个事吗？
这就是很神奇的状态，
就是我可能在二三年之前，
我的整个二十五岁之前，
我们家的沟通基榜是零沟通，
因为我爸妈是做生意，他们很忙，
他们可能早上六点出去就出去做生意，
然后我就是因为以前一个人在家里，
我一个人要解决，
就是从小学的时候我就开始自己做饭，
然后到晚上我睡着，
小学就开始自己做饭，
对，可能他们才回来，
我还记得我学的第一道菜就是那个豆豉铃鱼，
把那个豆豉铃鱼的罐头倒出来，
然后放在锅里热一下，
然后配米饭就可以吃了，
所以说一整个过往以来，
我们的沟通都很少，
我们是那种就是在我真正愿意主动给他们沟通之前，
我们是能可能过年三个人吃了饭一句话都没说，
然后就结束了。
不是，这个不存在什么儿行签里，
母担忧或者负担忧，
你去美国，
他们会把他们最想说的都含蓄的内联起来，
直到某一刻不得不爆发的时候才会爆发，
这是以前我们的沟通方式，
这个又严深出一点，
就是说我以前我会在很多时期都对育儿特别特别的有期望，
因为我总觉得如果我有孩子的话，
你会是个更好的爸爸，
我一定会跟孩子好好沟通，
我一定会好好照顾他们，
然后后来我发现我这个想法错了，
其实我根本对育儿没有任何的期望，
我只是没有完成这样的一个跟父母的沟通的课题，
所以我把这个课题转接给育儿这样一件事情了。
然后那一刻我了解的时候，
我发现我依旧有时间可以去跟我爸爸好好沟通，
我依旧有时间可以告诉他们我的心理化和可以跟他们多拥抱，
多聊天，多讲心事，
然后我记得当我完成了这样一个认知，
然后我第一次做的时候，
那是我去做动作他们送我的时候，
我妈妈因为可能更感兴一点嘛，
我跟她拥抱那些都没事，
我第一次，只要Litter里人生第一次跟我爸与抱的时候，
她坐在副驾上，
我上去我想跟她抱一下的时候走了，
然后她往后躲闪，
就是她的眼神里就没有意料到会有这种事情发生，
对，当时对又好哭又好想起。
但是慢慢慢慢的我们这几年的沟通会好很多很多很多。
但是在我当下当时读社的时候，
我们基本上是从不沟通的，
他们也不会告诉我家庭的状况，
也从来不会告诉我收入，
不会告诉我他们在做的事情，
就是我只能通过我能得到的信息去猜到底发生了什么。
对，你前面讲的时候，
我会觉得这个爸妈好冷漠啊都不关心你，
但是当你讲你试图去拥抱你爸爸，
你爸爸下意识的往后躲的时候，
就又忍不住会让人有点心疼，
因为就能想到可能他的成长过程中也没有人好好地抱过他。
是，是，因为他们都是各自家里的老大，
他们一路背负着就是说要带弟弟妹妹走出去赚钱，
或者说生存下去的压力，一直做生意，
然后一直在外面尝当，
然后一直忙碌。
反正当时的话就是我完全的就是我知道，
可能我没有任何的经济知识就全部要靠自己了。
所以说我就开始全部的经历，
就是空闲的读书之外的经历，
拿去做小龙虾。
你怎么就接受了这个设定？
要活下去嘛。
那个时候很小哎。
对，但那个时候其实没有想那么多，
就是只想着解决问题。
如果我没有钱我就去解决钱的问题。
没有想过回国或者是退学吗？
我当时读书是三年半毕业的，
三年半毕业的原因是，
因为我知道大四的如果我再多读一个学习，
我们一定付不起学费。
我当时记忆很深，
因为那个学期我周一到周五，
会去我们那个学校旁边的奶茶店上班，
然后下了班就去上课，
然后周末就做小龙虾，
然后去cover了我整个的所有的生活费用。
你毕业之后我相信很多人会很想念你的。
对，当时我能通过坚持家做小龙虾，
一个月的话可以赚三千刀，
来满足自己的生活。
我好厉害啊。
回国工作之后我发现我完全赚不到这么多。
对，这里我得插一个背景问题，
因为你前面说过最早录取你的是语言学专业，
可后来你一直在做酒店和餐饮相关的工作，
所以是在读书那几年你是转了专业吗？
就是去转专业学酒店和餐饮管理吗？
对，我是在大一第一个学期结束的时候，
我就明显知道了我不喜欢语言学的专业，
因为我开始做小龙虾，
我就想了解整个厨房系统，
我就想了解整个的餐饮，
我想去餐厅上班，
这样我更多的能知道怎么卖这些东西，
怎么做这些东西。
感觉天生就是做生意的量。
另一个很有意思的运气，
实际上就是当时我的室友，
他和我的路径基本上一样，
他也是选了一个他不喜欢的专业去到我们学校的，
但是恰恰他生学老师给亚报的那个他不喜欢的专业，
是酒店和餐饮管理。
所以你们俩有专业互换吗？
他没有去过我的专业，
他就在上学业，
然后他刚好把我介绍给了他的导师。
所以那一刻就是整个大学的专业的话，
可能是我第一次知道我喜欢什么，
我想要什么。
第一次为自己的人生做主。
做的第一个决定，
他后续真的影响了很多。
后续的话，
我来到上海找工作的时候，
我完全没有想过我在学校读书的做小龙虾经历，
和我的酒店管理和餐饮管理的这样一个专业，
可以帮助我在餐厅找到一个起点，
高于一般正常水平的这样的一个职位。
就是我去到了，
也就是我后来带了非常久的一个餐厅，
在那里做的特别稳定。
你刚才讲转到酒店和餐饮管理，
可能是你第一次很明确地知道，
这个是我喜欢的事情，
我愿意把时间和精力花费进去。
那后来到了上海，
你也一直沿着这条路走了很久，
从一开始的运营岗位，
一路往上坐到了总经理。
就听起来，
这份工作对应来说，
它不只是一种谋生手段，
它是你真的非常喜欢的行业，
那后来为什么你会动摇呢？
因为去年你离开了上海，
离开了那家餐厅，
是对做餐饮这件事情产生了怀疑，
还是说，
这份工作到后期发生了一些变化呢？
其实在我的之前的工作里，
我也非常坚定，
我就是想在这样的一个行业里一直坐下去，
但是在二五年离职的时候，
我发现了，
或者说我对这个行业有了一个不一样的想法，
离职的原因是因为，
我当时是公司的总经理，
但是当时的餐饮环境不是很好，
那老板会对于营业状况做出相应的一个调整，
无法完全地符合客人没有关系的，
但是我想成本降上来，
所以说在中间，
一个是老板还给员工做了一个薪资缓发，
这样的一个行为，
相当于把员工的一部分薪资磕扣下来，
他说等我们度过难关之后再发放给你们。
这么坏的老板就应该接发他，
但是出于行业操守我知道你肯定不会说的。
对，而且我也挺喜欢我们餐厅的，
而且我们餐厅的主厨我也很尊敬，
因为他是一个他和我一起共读的那样一个时期，
他跟我一起同样面对了这样的员工，
暂缓一部分薪资的时候我们为了维持住餐厅的整个，
不管是服务还是出品，
我们用自己的工资去补了员工，
他们被缓发的那个部分。
你是真的很热爱这个行业？
对，因此而来的一些冲突会让我进一步的意识到，
就是哪怕是任何一个公司，
任何一个餐饮集团，
如果真的喜欢做餐饮，
那么你最终不管到哪个位置面对的，
都是金钱和你自己的喜好的一个冲突，
就是永远会有股东和老百是想要赚更多的钱，
永远会有很热爱的工作人员和主厨，
想呈现出最好的一面给客人。
我觉得在这样的一个职业体系里，
我做到这个位置我无法找到答案和解法，
那我当时我对自己的职业想的是，
那我可能摆在自己面前的，
如果我依旧想做自己喜欢这个行业，
我可能最终只有两条路，
第一条是我去放弃掉这么多的社会气候，
就是说你要做个好职业，
或是说你要有个好的薪资，
我只在我喜欢的餐厅里做自己喜欢的服务，
但是这一条需要极端的一个经济的一个知识，
它可能是一个更任性的一个状态。
那么另外一条极端路就是说，
我成为这个餐厅的所有人，
我有资金，我有职业。
对，你来开一家自己喜欢的餐厅，
对对对，那这一条和单纯做服务那条，
他们都是同样需要一些经济知识和经济知识，
所以说为了这样的经济知识，
我其实在上海纠结了很久，
我改了自己的解离，
但是我也学好了我想去的地方，
我之中还是没有决定在头身中，
因为我当时其实从4月份开始一直空闲到7月份，
我中期三个月时间特别焦虑，
我觉得那种没有工作的可耻感就游然而生，
但是我最终了解了我可能就是说我的目标是。
可以向我刚才说的前往那两个方向的极端而去拥有经济知识，
那么我可以适当的向我的生活妥协，
所以说我回到了我们家里的生意，
我们家里的生意是在山西，
我觉得听到这里很容易让大家误会，
老李他并不是那种很传统意义上的回去继承家业，
因为老李在头高里也写到今年差不多是家里经历遍固后的第十年，
很多债务和过去的事情是在过去几年慢慢清理的，
所以无论是先回到老家还是到现在的山西，
老李更多的是向和爸妈一起创业，
努力把生意把自己的小家经营的越来越好，
对，是的，但是让我真正下决定离开上海的不是这个原因，
不是回家里帮忙这个原因，是很神奇的是我中间听了一期关于纳瓦尔的book，
他应该是跟Trace Williams他们在Modern Wisdom的一期，
他的中间有个核心思想就是说决定许多人一生绝大部分生活质量的其实就只有三个决定，
第一个是你在哪里，哪个城市生活，第二个是你从事什么事情，第三个是你与谁一起，
我开始想就是说上海这个城市是我觉得对的那个城市嘛，
我发现了一个很令我自己惊讶的一个事实，
就是说我一开始并没有主动选择上海这个城市，
我之前来上海是因为我当时在以前的一段亲密关系中，
对方说我在上海工作，你也要来这里找工作，你跟我一起生活，
然后后来我在上海生活的期间结束了那段亲密关系，
然后直到我在二五年结束了，我做了很久的这段工作，
相当于所有之前让我在上海继续待遇着的理由都消失了，
理由不存在，对，对，然后开始重新回答我，重新思考，
我真的是自己选择在上海的嘛，答案是不是，
那么我应该去哪里呢？
我当时不知道答案，但是那个时候像纳瓦尔一样，
我的另外一位电子导师又出现了，对，是王阁，
我当时在看王阁的穷查理宝典，
他中间我学到最重要的就是逆向思维，
就是如果你不知道你想要什么，你就先排除你不想要的，
然后我想如果我不知道我想去的城市是哪里，
我先排除我不想要的，我已经在上海生活这么多年了，
我自己还想依旧在上海继续生活嘛，
我觉得可能上海不是答案，
我只知道上海不是答案，但是我不知道哪里是答案，
所以我决定我先回到原点，
我先迈出离开上海的第一步，
我可能才会走上我能去其他城市寻找的一个城市，
才是我真正生活的那一步，
然后我就一样觉得从上海搬离了，
可是做出这样的一个巨大的决定，
不会让你很没有安全感，很焦虑吗？
因为像你说的你之前对你的工作认同感是非常非常的强的，
然后你也是一个工作狂的状态，
包括你在投稿里说以前你每周基本上只休息半天，
从早上10点到晚上11点，
然后还要借助酒精去抵消压力，
你能跟我们形容一下你当时典型的一天是什么样吗？
因为餐饮行业我们天天都接触，
但是内部人你们一天需要做多少多少事情，
大家可能没有什么概念。
比如说我典型的一天的话，
早上我们9点钟要到公司去开会每天早上，
那个时候基本上有些是时候你要对财务，
有些时候要对采购，
有些时候要对主厨，
有些时候要对老板，
他可能每周会分不同的日期，
有些时候周一有些时候周四，
9点开会之后基本上到10点了，
我们餐厅是11点半开始营业，
我们可能10点半的时候所有员工就到了，
开始做营业前准备11点半开始营业到下午2点钟的时候，
我们会结束营业结束我们做体力的服务之后，
我们会在2点钟开始做活动的策划，
我们会有每个月的pop-up就是special events，
然后我们会重新设计菜单，
我们会对当前这个菜的成本重新核算，
我们要上新菜的话，
我们要重新设计，
然后我们要约拍摄，
然后把菜单呈现，
包括点评的预定，
点评的套餐，
点评的带进去，
我们要去重新设定，
因为一切当时的行为都以。
我们要尽可能的控制成本和创造营收和吸引更多的客人，
是说为此我们还要再找过来探店的达人，
或者说我们跟线上的平台再去聊，
同时我们还要另外一方的去跟供应商聊，
你能否给我更好的价格，
然后等这一些一切都过去之后基本上已经是。
不是，五适和晚适中间这么短短的几个小时能干完这么多事吗？
就是一个会接另外一个会，
就这个供应商来了，你等我一下，
等我跟这个供应商聊完，
好了我们再下一段，
然后供应商聊完跟员工聊，
员工聊完可能公司的更有部门聊，
然后开餐前再跟主厨聊一下，
我们晚上有哪些客人，
我们晚上预定情况是怎么样的，
我们最近还要做什么样的调整，
然后给员工排班，
再给员工做副盘，
我们每天结束，
今天用哪些不好的地方，
然后晚上我们从5点半开始，
开始一直到晚上的10点钟结束，
结束之后我们会收到，
我们会总结，我们会查账，
然后我们做清理，
然后再结束，
我的一周周一到周天，
除了周二，
我那个时候强行让自己周二休，
为什么？
因为我们的公司跟餐厅不在一个地方，
去公司里开会是在周二，
这样我尽可能就可以cover七天所有的事情，
所以说我休息那天去开会，
下午开完会之后，
然后开始休息，
然后再继续上班，
你就这么运转了五年，
简然就是铁人，
那个是特殊情况，
就是我们从24年的11月开始，
我以这样的一个节奏，
一直运转到了25年的4月，
之前可能稍微好一点，
之前的话一天半，
对一周的话会休一天半，
但是基本上所有的假期，
周末节假日，
可能都没有任何的可以休息的部分，
因为餐饮的话越是这样的时期就越忙碌，
对，老李在投稿里有一段话给我印象很深刻，
你说应该就是来上海做餐饮之后，
从一开始连1000块的酒店押金都付不起，
到拥有第一个2万，
第二年拥有第一个20万，
结束的时候有了自己的第一个100万，
就是如果只看照面上好像收获了很多，
但它依然不会让你找到非常强的价值感。
嗯，这个真的是回看来说特别有趣的一个事情，
我其实对整段金钱和储蓄上的改变，
最深刻的地方是我攒到自己第一个20万的时候，
那个时候我坐在自己的房间里，
我看着20万的时候，
我觉得我的人生有了无数种我以前没有的可能性，
因为我当时因为变国原因没有读研究生，
我觉得他至少在我可以打工作坚持的情况下，
他可以帮我卖出第一步，
我可以出去读研究生，
我可以换个城市生活，
我可以现在辞去这个工作，
他依旧可以维持我生活一段时间，
那个时候我的人生可能性开始显现出来了，
我当时其实也正经很久，
另外一个是我的消费水平不会再因为我的收入增长而增长了，
就是到20万的时候我的消费就是我平时吃了饭，
我可能12块钱的一碗面也能吃，
几百的Bistro也能吃，
我也不会去国内那种交涉意义的生活区买怎么样的奢侈品，
随着收入的挺神，
我所想买的东西，想要花费的东西，
他那个预值就在20万的这样的一个，
你有储蓄的这样一个消费区间里面了，
都能覆盖？
对，都能覆盖，都能覆盖，
所以说在25年结束的时候，
我攒到了自己的第一个100万，
我还对那天的印象也很深。
你真的很能赞钱，你可是在上海。
对，但是我平时也不会消费什么东西。
是因为没有时间去消费吗？
对，对，都在工作上，工作让我不消费，
而且因为做餐饮嘛，对吧。
那天我以前从来没有想过，
我以前可能有段时间可能会跟，
就像所有酬注满质的大学生们读书的时候那种誓言什么，
我要赚到100万或者说怎么样，
我要在多少岁之前有这样一个积蓄。
哇，我那天爬上来，我真的有的时候，
我发现一个事情就是什么，什么都没有变。
你也并不想改变任何事情？
对，就是我不会去觉得开心而去消费奢侈一下，
你会发现随之而来，
我不知道这样说是否太过不当或者说反而散或者不好，
就是说你那个时候才会发现有些人说的财富的增长，
并不会让你感到真正的快乐。
你会发现随之而来有很多事情，
你要做的依旧要做。
我以前曾经也是那个会在网上看到别人说有钱是真正的快乐，
我想去给他点赞的那种人。
就以前你看到有钱人在螢幕上说，
其实钱不能解决所有的问题？
是真一笔的，是真一笔。
解决不了他，你就是说这什么玩意，他在反而散。
对，对，对，是的，是的。
但是中间我觉得就像我看那玩意儿读芒哥一样，
我也看了很多关于钱的一些人质的一些书。
这在繁忙的工作之余，你还是有在意志阅读。
对，除了那种真正高压下的就是我特别特别忙的那几个月，
我在工作之一也会读书，
因为我发现我只能说就是如果我们类统的说，
但是我觉得我今天是在留学生里相对低的。
但首先我绝对不抱怨，
就是说我们家里发生任何事情。
我说我从拥有原始积累的速度一定是比别人慢的，
和我手上需要处理的问题，
我觉得相对比别人更多的，
因为我们可能是需要从复苏开始出发的。
中间我觉得学校最好一个习惯就是，
你要一直学那些做得好的人是怎么做的。
而且我发现你身上确实体现了芒哥一直强调的一点，
就是永远不要自怜，不要self-pity。
我发现你真的不抱怨，无论好的话的事情发生，
我感觉你的态度就一直是OK我接纳，
然后我去思考怎么样去解决问题。
是的，是的，但是真正能做到不要资源资来真的很难，
我发现就是说我中间学到另外一个东西，
加上芒哥这个资源资来我觉得我才彻底克服了。
它是一个叫相比经理论，
就是你可以举双手把手比作相比经，
你人生的一个位置就是脾筋的中间的那个点，
有两个方式可以让中间那个点往前，
一个是拉脾筋的另一头，
就是说你自己往前，
但是过往还在这里，
你拉脾筋的另一头它就会有一个问题，
就是说你的过往没有被处理掉，
就是未被解决的人生课题依旧在这里，
然后你越往前走你就会觉得越吃力，
因为它的张力就会变得越来越大，
然后让脾筋的中间往前的另外一个方式，
就是你把你的过往给压缩，
不断解决以前过往的事情，
它也是一种可以往前的方式。
这又是字面意义上的目望，往前走。
对对对，字面意义上的目方，
后来我就了解就是不要一直给自己一些敘事，
说我经历了什么，
哪些事情对我不公，
我觉得更重要是把这个事情敘事改变，
正是因为有这些事情，
这些事情在它推我往前，
这些事情在推我往前，
就是如果你对当下，
我们并没有在温宝少得到困扰，
就是我们依旧在城市生活呼吸空气，
可以吃饱，
然后如果你甚至还对当下这样的一个生活状态，
觉得还可以，说满足还可以的话，
那么所有把你带到过往的这些人和事情都足够的有意义，
而且它都每一环都特别重要。
我觉得一个绝对的最理想的状况，
肯定是我们要一直努力的方向嘛，
但是我能够感受到你身上对于过往经历的种种是有那种感恩之心，
或者是感激之情的。
是,是。
包括你前面有讲到，
当你走到第一个二十万的时候，
你意识到说，
之前你没有继续生造，
读严是考虑到很多经济的问题，
那二十万其实是足够让你在，
比如说勤工解决的同时，
然后把研究生读下来的。
但是其实你没有选择那条路，
我也会很好奇为什么后来你没有再去做这件事情。
我觉得是因为，
是因为我明确了自己喜欢的行业和我想要进入的两个极端了，
就是说要么成为一个餐厅的拥有者，
要么就是自由的去进入到任何一个自己想去的餐厅去享受服务的快乐。
我觉得我可能找到了解决的方向和目标了。
对，所以说我的目标就以需要更稳定他时的做好自己的原始积累，
同时随着我离开上海加入到家里的生意上，
这段经历他会多出来一个支线。
我觉得如果现在我回来，
那我有义务承担起那些我父母保护，
我不让我了解的所有的不管是债务也好，
以前的复杂状况也好，
我有意味同样跟他们承担所有，
直到我们真正的一起齐心行力解决之后，
就像是我擅自把这个纳入了我需要完成的一个任务，
我觉得我作为家里的议员同样也需要跟他们一起经历。
就可能我也不会在这里待太久，
可能这也只是我的一个阶段，
我最终还是要出去继续回去做我的餐饮的。
也还是要回到你的人生主线的。
对对对，对于我们来说，
这其实也像是一个礼物，
我们一起做这个生意，
我们一起沟通，
我们一起享受创业的这样的一个感觉，
我们不断地交流。
因为这就让我刚刚之前说的就是关于敘事，
今年很神奇的是我爸他过年回老家，
他在老家待了一个月，他很无聊，
他跟我说他过来跟我说我在老家什么事情都没事情干，
也没有人找我，我也不去应酬。
我说那你换一个角度去想这个事情，
有没有可能今年是给你的最好的机会，
你可以有最多的时间在家里好好陪爷爷，
好好跟他说话，
可能当你以后生意忙了，
或者说你的人生阶段又变了，
你又更少时间去老家的时候，
有没有可能今年他就是你最多时间那一年呢？
我也同样要告诉自己，
有可能之后我去进入我的人生下也觉得了，
有可能我成家了，
有可能我在另外一个城市生活了，
那会不会今年至少可以抓住的今年或者明年，
是我人生唯一能够父母有这么亲密的做事情，
沟通交流的时候呢，
我不得不好好地去珍惜他。
而且你刚才在讲这个事情的时候，
我就会在想说哇，你爸爸会跟你聊这些了也，
虽然可能现在有点晚，
但是他现在愿意对自己的儿子敞开心扉，
他会说这些事情，
以前他做不到的。
对对对，
他以前完全不说，他以前完全不说，
然后我会给他彭乔设计特别多so-called的中年男人的毛病啊等等等等，
你知道吗？
嗯对,
然后有一天他跟他说，
这个改变，
这个决定我听了你的，
怎么样？
我说挺好的，
他说不错啊，
他说我说是的，
他说跟你所讲的那些中年男人不一样了吧？
我说,
不一样了，
不一样了。
哎呀好，
我觉得真好，
就是我觉得换做10年前还在读书的你，
可能也没有想到现在的你可以和家人拥有这样的，
大家可以聊聊这个过年的感受啊这样的一个关系，
然后还可以一起面对很多更重大的课题，
一起背负起家庭的责任。
是的,
所以说有一天我妈突然说一句话他说，
好像我们这一刻才开始认识彼此，
妈妈说的话好深刻啊，
对,
我们以前都只是母子父子关系，
就是好像我们双方都从来没有把对方当一个独立的个体去了解他，
去了解他的性格去了解他的经历，
就是比如说对我来说，
我好像也是因为今年的经历才第一次去不以父母的这种标签去了解，
我只以他们俩他们是否是我尊敬的生意人，
他们是否是我尊敬的男性女性，
他们因为他们的童年经历了这么多事情，
他们现在为什么会有这些脾气，
为什么会有这些行为，
为什么会有这些思维，
我好像第一次才全然接受，
原来这样一个独立的个体，
他是之前他们家极子妹的老大，
他必须要强势，
他必须要走出来，
所以说我那一刻就全懂了，
就是他不再是只是以前一个我父母这样的一个角色，
我以父母的形式去跟他们沟通，
就真正的看见了彼此，
对,
是的,
那如果现在再用一句话来回答我们这次聊天的主题，
那在工作和金钱之外，
你觉得是什么支撑着你的价值感呢？
我觉得是相对行为自己真正想要的到底是什么，
我喜欢参议，
我可能会之后会一直在这条路上坐下去，
所以我现在做的一切事情都是以这个目标在做积累，
我中间即使在情况很严峻的时候都没有很轻易的放弃在工作上的坚守，
包括我有了一定财富积累之后，
我一直想回去做餐饮，
是因为我亲戚知道自己很想要他，
对,
我觉得他就像我最近看到的一个类似于鸡汤的话一样，
就是说你可以大胆的向宇宙索要你想要的东西，
就宇宙的菜单上有所有的菜，
有可能别人的菜单上只有炸鸡薯条汉堡，
是因为是这个社会给他的一个菜单的定式，
但是当你真正找到你想要的，
你想像宇宙点什么单的时候，
就我想点餐饮这个单的时候，
我先确保我是真的很想要他，
就是I really want it,。
然后去向宇宙传递信号，
然后做好自己的事情，
宇宙可能就会回应我。
所以对你来说这个答案是真正的认识自己，
知道自己喜欢什么想要什么，
想要往哪里走，
但你就自己有足够的了解，
那么你在做事情的过程中就不会反复的质疑自己，
去询问我做这件事情有没有加值了，
你的堵定感是来自这里吗？
对对,
当你把这些都做到了，宇宙的菜单上就其实是有，
一切你愿意想要的菜，
就非常符合你参与人的定位。
是的，因为这个很有意思，
就是说关于宇宙菜单这个事情是我上一期跟朋友，
也是跟一个餐饮的播客节目组做播客的时候我们聊到的，
然后那个观念瞬间就刷新了我，
他说了一句话，
就是说以前家里餐桌上大家吃的菜，
他是一家人的可无一偏好的综合。
第一个，对，
就是说你可能自己并不知道你想不想喜不喜欢吃香菜，
但这个家里因为有人不吃香菜，
是说你绝对从来没有吃到过有香菜的菜，
没有尝试过。
第二个点是一家人的菜，
决定吃什么是由这个提供者来决定的，
今天谁做菜就决定了家里你今天能吃到什么，
但是我们进到大学生活或者社会之后，
你会发现你自己成为了这种菜的一个提供者了，
你可以点任何你想要的，
但是大家会有惯性，
很多人都会被惯性带着走，
然后到后面慢慢的你会发现，
可能公司成为了这个菜品的提供者，
就是说你的路径，你的生殖路径全被定了下来，
可能这个社会的期望成为你人生这个菜单的提供者，
就是说你要结婚，你要生孩子，
你要金钱上或者社会地上得到成功，
这才算成功。
就是说你有机会可以自己成为自己宇宙菜单的提供者，
但重要的是你要先看看这个宇宙上一共多少种分别的菜，
这些为什么大家会说走出去或者说多尝试，
或者说多了解不同的专业，
不了解不同的领域、行业，
你要先看除了你以前固有的成长路径上出现的这些菜之外，
全国各地到底还有哪些其他菜，
然后自己给自己做。
把他们都吃一遍，
对，都吃一遍你就知道。
都找到最喜欢的。
对的，对的，都吃一遍你就找到你最喜欢的。
我觉得你这个比喻好妙啊。
我觉得最后就可以祝大家拥有一个好胃口，
以及找到自己真心喜爱的食物。
是，我觉得就是大胆的向宇宙点单，
你可以得到任何你想要的，
前提是你足够想要的。
好呀，那我觉得说在这里就特别的好。
再次感谢老李，
谢谢你的时间。
谢谢以外，谢谢，谢谢。
老李最后讲宇宙菜单的时候，
我觉得这个比喻特别妙，
因为他是一个菜引人嘛，
最后还是用点菜来理解人生。
可这个比喻真正打弄我的地方，
不是你想要什么，就一定能得到什么，
而是你要先知道这个世界上到底有多少菜，
有多少种选择。
很多时候我们以为自己在选择，
其实只是沿着已经摆在面前的菜单往下点。
家庭给过一份，学校给过一份，
工作和生活的城市也会给一份。
而老李更加厉害的一点是，
当他开始重新看自己的菜单，
他也带着父母一起打开了一点新的可能性。
以前他们一家很少沟通，
父亲是父亲，母亲是母亲，
儿子是儿子，
大家都在自己的角色里做该做的事情。
但后来他开始主动和父母聊天，
主动拥抱，
一开始把他们不只当做父母，
而是当做有个性、有思考，
有过往经历塑造的独立个体。
所以老李妈妈的那句话也很打动我。
他说，好像我们这一刻才开始认识彼此，
这也许也是一种重新点菜，
不再只吃父母子女这道默认的菜式，
而是开始问，
作为三个具体的人，
我们能不能重新认识一次，
重新再坐在一张桌子上？
我觉得这个转变特别的宝贵。
以上就是今天我一天又的故事。
如果你觉得这一期节目有收获有启发，
欢迎你把它转发给某个此刻，
可能需要听到这些故事的人。
我相信他会感受到你的心意。
这些故事会录完之后，
我想起了最近的一部电视剧，
叫《所有人都在和自己的无价值做对抗》。
我是不是一个有价值的人？
这个问题可能不会每天都出现在脑海，
但他一定会在人生的某个时刻突然冒出来，
可能是在工作没有得到认可的时候，
在收入停滞的时候，
在一段关系里感到错败的时候，
也可能是在我们很努力很努力，
却还是事与愿违的时候。
听完这五位天佑的故事，
我会觉得价值感也许不止来自于那些被看见的结果。
他也可能来自小洋让我看到的那种感受里，
在很多事情无法被解决，也无法被改变的时候，
依然愿意认真感受正在发生的每一天。
也可能来自313的选择，
曾经我没有被好好对待过，
但我仍然想成为一个善良、负责、愿意照顾别的生命的人。
也可能来自小猫终于意识到，
我不能再用面子和隐瞒把自己推回同一个陷阱里。
真正重要的第一步是承认问题已经发生，
然后停下来去面对它。
也可能来自爱饭后来慢慢明白的道理，
工作不是生活的唯一指点。
健康、爱好、朋友和家人，
他们值得更多的时间和关心。
也可能来自老里，在过去一年的持续练习，
不再只是沿着生活的惯性往前走，
而是试着听从自己的内心，
做真正属于自己的选择。
这些东西听起来不像一个项目开机，
一笔收入道障，
一个抬头变化那样容易被看见，
被量化，
但他们会把我们重新拉回到具体的生活当中。
也许价值感不只是证明我有用，
它也包括在那些具体的事情，
日子和羁绊里感受到我是真实存在的，
我和这个世界还有连接。
我觉得这也是这期故事会最打动我的地方。
那下一期的小酒馆故事会，
我们打算和房产万事屋这个系列做一次联动，
聊一个很具体的问题。
你最近一次关于房子的决定是什么？
它可以是买房，也可以是卖房，换房，租房，
叙租，退租，装修，
或者决定，暂时不买房。
过去几年，关于房子的很多共识都在变化。
以前很多人会默认，
到了某个年纪就一定要买房，
房子是安全感，是资产，
也是一个人在城市里扎根的证明。
但这两年，越来越多的人开始重新考虑，
我到底还需不需要买房？
在哪里买？什么时候买？
要不要卖掉？
要不要把更多的钱花在租一个更舒服的地方？
所以，这次我们想请你分享的，
不是房产判断，也不是投资建议，
而是你的具体故事。
你为什么做出了那个决定？
这个决定背后有哪些现实压力，
家庭讨论，亲密关系里的分歧，
或者你心态上的变化？
做完这个决定之后，你的生活有什么不一样吗？
如果在过去一年里，
你刚好经历过和房子有关的决定，
欢迎你和我们分享你的故事。
你可以在我们的文稿区找到问卷链接，
也可以通过小酒馆的社交媒体，
向我们私信投稿。
那在节目最后，也要和大家汇报一个好消息。
有志有行和陈鹏博士合作推出的。
中国大力资产投资2025年报，
线上版已经更新了。
这份年报系统整理了中国。
过去21年的大力资产风险和收益数据，
也参考了海外更长期的市场经验。
帮助我们理解不同资产在长期里。
到底提供了什么样的回报，
又需要承担什么样的风险。
他也许不能告诉我们明天的市场会涨还是会跌，
但可以帮我们在投资这张菜单面前，
更清楚的知道自己点的是什么，
将面临什么样的波动，
又为什么值得长期留下来。
与此同时，我们也为大家准备了一枚投资的常识徽章。
你可以打开有志有行app，
点击首页活动入口，
阅读中国大力资产投资2025年报，
并且在评论区分享一个你印象最深的数据或者图表，
或者是一个被刷新了的投资常识，
就有机会获得这枚好看的徽章。
祝你在生活里有一个好胃口，
在投资里也有一份更全面的菜单。
最后请别忘记订阅我们的节目，
有空的话给我们留一个五星好评，
会成为我们2026年前进的动力。
我是羽白，
每周晚8点和你相约在小酒馆，
我们不见，不散。